(Joey beatboxing)
(Connor thumping)
(Connor claps)
- Can't believe you used the wrong mike.
- I'm sorry.
(gentle music)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of "Trash Taste".
I'm your host for today, Garnt
and joining me once again are the boys.
(Joey sneezes)
Jesus Christ.
- Sorry.
- [Garnt] God dammit Joey.
- We had it, we had it.
- We had the perfect take,
which was the only take
we've ever done today.
You know.
Outtakes on
patreon.com/trashtaste, of course.
- Damn, trying to lash it out early.
- Yeah, of course, of course. Right.
- I spilled half of this on me.
- Oh, my fucking...
Guys, I thought we were professionals.
We've been doing this-
- The hay fever season's fucking...
- We've been doing this for
almost like two years, now.
We should be on this man,
we should be on this.
- Fucking hell.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Sheez, a vine boom sound effect.
- Boom.
I'm just, yeah, I've been just...
hay fever's been kicking
my ass this season.
- Really?
- Yeah, all of a sudden.
I hate it.
- Yeah.
- And especially like now,
when you're sniffling on a train
and you just see like all these like...
'Ey, oh.
Is this boy sick or-
- Some Japanese guys have like these
most aggressive gravelly coughs, dude.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They come out of nowhere.
I don't how they have cough-
(Garnt coughs)
- You hear that every so often.
- Always-
- I don't know how they do it.
- Exactly that noise.
- Especially in COVID.
Deep in COVID season as well,
you're just like, you're
on high fucking alert, man.
I'm like one of those
guards in (indistinct),
the fucking alert pops
up and I'm just like, oh.
- I actually saw at my local bookstore,
they were selling these
pins during the pandemic,
in the middle of the
pandemic, that just said,
like during hay fever season.
It was a pin that just said,
"Don't worry, I have hay fever".
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
And so people would like,
if there was sniffling on the train,
you'd just like show off
the badge and be like,
"I don't have COVID guys,
it's just hay fever."
- But what if you had COVID
and you bought that anyway,
just to be like, guys it's hay fever.
- Trust me. Trust me.
- What if you had both?
- 'Cause I remember,
'cause I also had like a
little bit of hay fever,
but also I remember one week,
I just got like a cough or something
and getting a cough
during the pandemic time
is like the worst, right.
'Cause normally it feels bad
to cough in public anyway.
But you're like, when you have like just,
it's just like a dry cough, especially,
you're so conscious about it, right?
About how often you're coughing
and it just makes the cough,
when you are thinking about it,
it just makes the cough 10 times worse.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- And especially on public
transport, you're just...
I remember like normally,
going to my old place,
it would be stressful if I
needed to take a shit. Right?
(Joey laughs)
You know, when you're holding it in,
I was holding in this fucking cough
and fucking spacing this
cough out that I had,
for a good 40 minutes or
however long that journey was.
And I dunno if anyone
around me noticed it,
but I was like, I dunno, I was just,
I was fucking sweating from how much
I was trying to hold in this cough.
- I thought you were holding in the cough,
'cause you didn't wanna shit
yourself in the process,
like (imitates cough)
- Just do it.
I'm just gonna be like, I'm gonna do it.
Who cares? What are they gonna do?
It's not like a zombie apocalypse, right?
If you've been bitten,
they're gonna kill you.
- Have you ever coughed
and shit at the same time?
- No, what, what?
(Joey laughs)
- No?
- We were not talking about shitting yet.
Yeah, Twitter.
I'll leave it for the vlogs.
- Do you have a story, Joey?
- No.
(Garnt laughs)
Just curious.
- What?
- I dunno, just...
- You've never done that?
- Of course I've done it.
- I've never done that.
- I don't have a story about it.
- Of course I've done it.
I have also, we've all done it.
We haven't all done that.
- I have never done
that, unfortunately Joey.
Sorry I can't...
- Sorry, I'm sorry man, I wish we could...
- It's a sensation.
- So, are you on the toilet or?
- Yeah, of course I'm on the toilet.
- Okay, that doesn't
count, that doesn't count.
- No, that's what I mean,
I don't mean like...
I'm not asking you to be like,
have you shat yourself before?
Like in public? I think we've already-
- I shat myself on the toilet.
- We've talked about that one.
- Yeah, but yeah, no,
just like on the toilet and you just like,
it's not coming out and then
you use the power of the cough
to exert your body.
(both laugh)
- That's how you get hemorrhoids.
- You know what, let's change the subject.
- This is how you get
hemorrhoids, I'm pretty sure.
- I think the only thing
that comes close to that
isn't like shitting yourself.
But it's when you go back to the gym
for the first time in ages.
You have ab day or something.
And the day after your entire body aches
and the one time you sneeze,
it just pushed your entire
body into pain mode.
- It's like (screams)
- I literally did this like two weeks ago.
I did ab day for the first time in months.
And not one day, it was
like five days afterwards.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Why was it lagging?
- Dude, no, no, it was like
for the next five days.
- Oh, like in a row.
- It hurt so much.
- I see, I see.
Damn, you went hard.
- I just went too hard,
man, I just went too hard.
I don't know, what can I say?
- Talking about seasons though.
Can Japan chill with
its changing of seasons?
I dunno.
Last week it felt like winter.
It felt like it was coming
on the tail end of winter.
It was warming up a little bit.
- Yeah.
- And I think we had two days of spring,
like spring weather.
And I remember going out yesterday
or the day before in this jacket
and I was sweating my ass
off already and I just...
Japan, I've just noticed,
it doesn't have a transition period.
You just wake up one day
and it's a new season.
- And they say Japan has four seasons.
What a load of shit.
- It's such a lie, Japan has two seasons.
It's hot or cold.
- It is, it is two.
It's winter and summer,
that's all they have.
- It's like different stages of cold
and then just different stages of hot.
There's no warm.
There's no warm period, you get like-
- The warm period is maybe in the evening
when the sun's just gone down
and the residue of the
concrete heat is escaping.
That's when it's like, "Okay,
that's kind of pleasant".
But then immediately
afterwards it's just like,
"Oh, now it's cold as shit,
'cause you're in a t-shirt like an idiot."
- I always forget how hot it
is until the summer comes.
And then I'm like, "Oh
yeah, this is hell".
- I think it's like trauma for me.
I forget about it and
I'm like, "Summer, what?"
I'm winter game, bro. I'm wearing a coat.
And I forget that for
half the year in Japan,
you just can't wear more than one t-shirt.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Unless you're a Japanese person-
- Who can wear a full
suit and an overcoat.
- Yeah, and it'd be like,
"Oh, it's a little dab
of sweat right here".
- What temperature is in the office?
Can we have 30 degree
Celsius, please? What?
- Yeah, I dunno how I
walk around in the summer
and just see business
people in full on suits,
running along with their briefcase
and I'm here dying in
my t-shirts and shorts.
- I'm a sweater, I'm a big sweater boy.
- I am as well.
- I sweat like a motherfucker.
- I am.
I'm the complete opposite of Sydney
because she doesn't sweat enough
when it comes to heat.
We're deep in summer
and I feel her forehead
and it's just like,
there's zero perspiration.
- Yeah, Aki's exactly the same.
I'm like, that's how you get heat stroke.
- My body's working.
- Yeah.
- If you sweat a lot, that's healthy.
- Technically.
- Water away
- Is it?
- Get all the water away.
(Joey laughs)
That's why I weigh so much.
- To me, it's like it's
a copium, it's healthy.
I feel like the tiniest bit of heat
and my armpits, especially,
just start perspirating.
And there's no way,
that doesn't ruin anything you
fucking wear, unfortunately.
So I just have to be
worried in the summer,
even if I'm not...
even if I'm underneath air conditioning,
I still sweat sometimes.
- For me, it's weird.
I don't sweat through my armpits as much.
For me, it's all in the face,
which is horrible because
you can't hide that shit.
- You're literally like
that meme of that guy.
I don't know, he's on the radio.
He's like (imitates sweating)
- Yes.
- Fuck it, fuck it.
I'm like that Key & Peele gif,
where it's just like dripping wet,
but the rest of my body
is okay, I hate it.
- But yeah, I guess that's why...
we're from England, right?
Do you feel like being British
has conditioned you to like cold weather
or do you feel like you've
gotten used to other climates?
- I don't think it's the temperature.
It's more so the sun,
I think we're... I'm allergic to the sun.
I don't like the sun.
- Is that 'cause you're white?
- Yeah, no, very white, very white.
Very white, indeed actually.
- But you know, I would understand
because you guys have that lack of sun,
right, in the UK.
- Yeah.
- But in Australia we
have an overdose of sun.
So I'm also traumatized by too much sun.
- Yeah.
- As well.
Because in Japan it's like
sometimes the sun works
and then sometimes it works overtime.
- I still think the summer
was worse in the UK than it was in Japan
because we don't have AC.
- How hot does it get, though?
- Oh yeah.
- So it's three, four weeks of...
at least the last time I was there.
It was like three, four weeks
of just uncomfortable sweating,
and I can't do anything.
At least in Japan I can game all day
in a comfortable AC climate room. Right?
Yeah, okay, when I go outside it sucks.
I sweat, but I'd take that
over having, be in my bedroom,
sweating and being able to do nothing.
- That's true, that's true.
- It's horrible.
You get one of those fans that blows air,
but I feel like that's
literally like a copium.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It doesn't do anything.
- You just blowing the air around.
- It's just blowing the
hot air into my face.
- I actually like the fan.
Like sometimes I-
- I think that's a Southeast Asian thing.
- I think it is, I think it is.
- I think Asian people, they love fans.
I swear, they just like fans all the time
- To me, you admit defeat if
you are putting on the AC.
Right, that means you are more weak-
- Why is the fan any different?
- I dunno, the fan, I
like the feeling of hot.
Not exactly cold air.
- Would you say you're a fan?
- Fuck off Joe, fuck off.
I dunno.
- Just stand under the AC.
- Because to me, the
AC, it just feels like,
how can I put this?
It feels like artificial air.
- I get it...
- Does that make sense?
- No, I understand that the AC air
is not one you wanna be breathing in?
I don't know why.
- Yeah.
- It feels weird.
- 'Cause I feel the
same way about heaters,
where if you have...
There's a difference in having a warm room
and having a room that's
been warmed up by a heater,
'cause it feels 10 times
more stuffy for some reason.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- I don't like the feeling
of just the artificial heat
as opposed to just being in a country
or in a temperature that is comfortable,
like naturally outside.
Same thing with AC, for me.
With AC, if you have a
room that's cooled with AC,
it just feels, I don't
know, like the air...
How can I describe this?
It feels like, it feels sterile.
(Connor and Joey laugh)
You know what I mean?
- No, I don't know what you mean.
- [Garnt] It feels sterile.
- This is first world problems.
- It is first world problems.
- I agree, I agree.
- I breathe it in, it's
just unnaturally dry.
Sometimes, my asthma, my lungs,
feel the dry air way more with AC air
than with just cold air in general.
I don't know, it's completely something
that is just a me issue,
but that's why I much prefer having a fan
as opposed to having the AC. Right.
- Did I tell about why my
apartment smelled like shit
for the first two months?
- Your current apartment?
- Yeah.
- Why?
- Well, it involves the AC.
- Like literal shit, or...
- Like literal shit.
- Is it 'cause of the AC?
- Yeah, so you know I moved
into this apartment building.
Something just kept smelling weird.
I couldn't put my finger on it. Right.
And I'm like, "What the
fuck is this thing?"
I turn the AC off, right?
- Yeah.
- It's still coming in.
So my apartment still smells like shit.
This is brand new, I just got this place.
Why does it smell of shit?
It's not me, I'm definitely flushing.
- Looks down, I'm covered in shit.
- I foul up, but it's not that kind of...
it's like a lingering.
No matter where I am,
I'm getting this, right.
So I go to my balcony, right,
and there's like, bird shit.
And I'm like, "Well, it can't
be that 'cause I clean it,
and it still smells of shit".
I'm like, "What the fuck is going on?
Why does it smell of shit?"
Turns out that there was this one place
where these birds were shitting,
that was like, the
intake fan was right here
and all the birds were just shitting
right next to the intake.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
And I couldn't see it
'cause it's right next...
there's this much gap between the roof
and the box they're shitting on.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- Right.
- It's literal perfect size
for one pigeon to fit in.
and they loved, loved, shitting there.
I don't know why they loved it.
Maybe 'cause they felt like the
roof was close, it was nice-
- So you basically were
huffing in bird shit.
- I literally, for two
months, was just huffing in,
and I'm pretty sure that pigeon poop
is one of the poops you
don't wanna be breathing in.
- I think any poop is.
- I don't wanna breathe
in any poop, to be honest.
- As in, I think they have one of the more
dirty poops out there, I believe.
I don't know if this is correct.
Compared-
- As compared to what?
- Compared to what poop?
- Listen, if I laid a log there,
it's not gonna smell as bad.
- Is there a poop scale
of hygiene quality?
I think it's just like
all poop, right, surely.
- I remember, when I Googled
cleaning pigeon poop,
there's a bunch of things that were like,
warning, please make sure you
don't actually touch the poop,
'cause it's filled with
disgusting parasites and stuff.
- When isn't it filled with
disgusting germs and parasites?
- I don't know, I play
with mine all the time
and it's not that bad.
(all laugh)
It could have been just a generic warning.
Anyway, so I cleaned
it and then I was like,
"Great, this is amazing, it's all fixed.
My apartment doesn't smell of shit."
Two days later I start
smelling shit again.
They just kept coming back.
So, fuck...
So, I then had to install
those spikes on it.
- Oh yeah.
- To get rid of it.
And finally, now my apartment
doesn't smell of shit,
unless I leave the door
open and take a shit.
Then it does smell of shit.
- I was gonna ask how you've
sorted the problem, 'cause I...
- My apartment is a... my
balcony is like a joke.
It's like half reflective now.
I've put reflective stuff everywhere
and it doesn't stop them.
They just find a new spot.
- I noticed that 'cause in my house
and in my home in Thailand,
it's on the outskirts of the city.
So it's more next to nature,
the nature side of things.
And I notice the spikes
do fucking nothing, man.
The spikes is a great place
for birds to start a nest.
So like-
- Oh, really?
These are like comically large spikes.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- I literally don't get
any birds on my balcony.
- You're so lucky. How does that work?
- I don't know.
- How do pigeons decide
this is the building
that I'm gonna fuck up.
- Maybe one pigeon is
like, "Oy, check it out."
- Yeah, 'cause sometimes-
- Come on, come on.
- Sometimes we get that one fucking pigeon
that's hanging out outside
the toilet of this office
and I can hear fucking it.
I don't know why...
it's here and in Thailand as well,
why the first thing I hear when I wake up,
is just these birds going at each other.
(Joey imitates pigeons cooing)
It's not even that, right,
it's not even pigeon.
Sometimes it's just like...
sometimes it is, I swear, it's
just like the fucking ghetto.
Like it's the fucking
ghetto of the birds, right.
And I can just hear is like,
"Oi, oi mate, what you doing here?
What are you doing here, mate?
Bruv, bruv, what are you doing?"
And I'm just like-
(Joey imitates shooting)
(both laugh)
Every fuck morning, I
don't know what it is.
And so we installed spikes
to try and stop these birds
from hanging out outside,
like stop 'em loitering.
Stop the youths from loitering
outside of our window.
- I wanna see these spikes you're using.
- It's just like the plastic spikes.
It's just like that.
- Maybe use plastic and they
just didn't do anything.
- I don't know, but we thought, okay,
we're gonna install them to stop the birds
hanging out here every morning.
It did the entire fuck opposite
because now they found out that the spikes
are great for propping up a nest there.
So they just built a nest there.
So, we literally helped them settle down.
- At that point, you just
gotta give them credit.
That's just impressive.
- Big brain.
- So yeah, unfortunately-
- I'd rather the birds though,
'cause in Australia I would wake up
to possums fucking on our roof.
- What does that sound like?
- It just sounds...
it's just like a lot of rattling like this
and a lot of like (screeches)
at two in the morning.
I'm like, "Oh my God, please stop."
- That sounds pretty good.
- No, it's not.
How does that sound good?
- Do they make a mess?
- I hope not.
- Well, if you hope not, that
means you don't know. Right?
So that must mean they
probably don't make a mess.
- I mean, the mess is
like half the problem.
It's the fact that I can't get to sleep
'cause these possums are-
- I'd rather have trouble sleeping
than have to clean the
shit up every two months.
- Yeah.
- It's awful, they shit on
my Ikea furniture as well.
- Oh, because you got furniture
out on your balcony as well.
- So, wherever I put the
reflective stuff down,
they just move
and then I put the
reflective stuff right above-
- What is the reflective stuff?
- It's like-
- Like CDs?
- What's those?
The Coloso scopes? No,
what are they called?
- Kaleidoscopes?
- That's it?
The kaleidoscopes kind
of patterns that reflect
and it just scares them off.
But sometimes it doesn't
and then other times
they just, it's like they're edging.
They'll find a spot and
they'll have one foot on
and they'll just start shitting off of it.
And I'm like, "How am I
supposed to predict this?
This is insane."
- That was very different edging to watch.
- But then they're.
- They're standing on the edge, right?
- I was like, the pigeons are doing what?
- They're probably edging as well.
- They're just like, ah, ah, ah.
- They're probably doing that as well.
- Direct eye contacts,
just like, ah, ah, ah.
- It's awful. It's awful.
And they're like...they...
oh, it's such a pain in the ass.
- Yeah, 'cause...
- Pain in their ass, too.
- Do you ever have to deal with
annoying wildlife in the UK?
- No.
- Do you guy's have
any wildlife in the UK?
- I feel like the most annoying
thing for me in the UK is,
I dunno if you have it in Wales,
but in the city, in Brighton at least,
or at least when I was living
in London as well, foxes.
The sound that they make
sometimes at night just is,
is the worst screech I've
ever heard in my life.
- You guys have foxes?
- Yeah, we do have foxes.
- Oh, wow.
- It's like the deadliest animal we have.
- They're fucking pussies, though.
- Yeah, they are, they run away.
- Because you make eye
contact with 'em, they run,
they're already down the road,
like fucking legging it down a mile.
- I used to live above
a bunch of restaurants,
so always saw foxes, but
they never made noise.
- They never made noise?
- No.
- No, actually they never make noise
if they're in the vicinity
of guys or humans.
But I would sometimes hear them
just screeching off in the background.
And they literally sound like, I dunno,
like a kid being assaulted
or something, right.
Because I remember the first
time Sydney moved to England,
she heard this noise and she
was about to phone the police.
I was like, "No Sydney,
that's just a fox."
'Cause it just sounds like (screeches)
(Joey laughs)
- You just hear that in the background,
and I'm just like... the
first time I heard it,
I was like, "What is that noise?"
- At least that's what they tell you,
like, "It's the foxes."
- It's the foxes.
- Trust.
- Enters the door with plastic gloves on.
It's the foxes.
- It's the foxes, yeah.
- Yeah. I know.
- We only had ants.
- Ants?
- Yeah, we had ants.
- Ants that would get into the house.
They're pretty good, ants are.
They're really good at
getting into your house.
- Yeah.
- But the British ants are tiny though.
Like fucking...
Can they even be called ants?
- But when there's a lot of them.
- Yeah, but that's the problem with it.
- It's not just a single ant.
- Ants don't travel solo.
They're not like fucking
wolves. They're not like...
- You don't see a single
ant in your house,
and you're like, "Oh, fuck."
- They're normally like,
they're very kind though, ants.
They have a nice line that directs you
to exactly where they came from.
They're really, really
considerate in that sense.
But they'd get into
the bread bin and stuff
and they'd get into like-
- Yeah, like the sugar
containers and stuff.
- They're really good at finding it.
- We had that a lot.
- They're so good at finding it.
- You think you've sealed
that bread box up tight.
- I can't find where the snacks are hidden
in my house, sometimes.
- So I have to follow the trail.
- My parents would hide them,
but the ants would always find them.
They'd always lead me to them.
- I'd never really had such
a big ant problem in the UK.
It was more when I was in Thailand.
- [Connor] It might be where you live.
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause
whenever I'm in Thailand,
if you have a piece of food out
or you drop a tiny bit
of crumb or something,
a timer starts right before you,
the timer starts before
you can clean it up,
otherwise the ants are
gonna clean up for you.
And then you're just
kinda have a line of ants
just marching through your home.
And the thing about Thai ants
is that they're pretty
fucking big as well.
- I'd rather them be big
though, easier to kill.
- No, no, no.
No, no, no.
- Assume it's like a super villain.
You know when you step on an ant?
- Yeah.
- And it doesn't die.
And you're like, what?
This is how the villains feel in movies
when their attack doesn't work.
What do you mean my attack failed?
- But, in the UK, ants are
just a slight annoyance,
because what the fuck can
they do to you, right.
- What do you mean,
they can eat your food.
They make it like...
- Yes, slight annoyance.
- Slight annoyance.
- That's very big annoyance.
- They don't bite you or
anything, like some do.
- I'd rather them bite
me than take my food.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Have you ever been bitten by an ant?
- Not yet.
- Yeah, I don't think
you'll say the same thing
once you get bitten by one.
- Not like the fucking...
What's that guy called on YouTube?
Coyote Peterson or whatever.
Not those kind of ants where he's like,
"Well, my hand has swollen in
19 times the original size.
I could scarcely breathe,
but this is mildly painful."
- Even if it's something like, you know,
even if it's not like
toxic or super painful,
that is more of an annoyance
than the ants eating your food.
- No, no.
If it was a mild pain, I'd
rather that than have to like...
- What if it's a lot of mild pains
'cause it's a lot of ants.
- A lot of mild pains.
- A lot of mild pains,
what does that mean?
- Because you're not gonna get-
- Can you an example
of a lot of mild pain?
- Well, because, you know, there is...
- Can you give me another example?
- Because you're not gonna,
because when an ant bites you
that just invites the
other ants to also attack.
- What's going on where I'm
gonna give them a second chance?
- You never know.
- What is this?
- You'd be like, "Ooh, that hurt.
Another, another please."
- Again, yes, again.
- One more time.
- Put them on my nipples, please.
Bite me again.
(all laugh)
- Do you have to deal with any
annoying pests in Australia?
- That is the entry requirement.
When you get in the border, they're like,
"Oh mate, do you mind if a
koala bites on your toes, mate?
- No, for what?
I don't even think I've ever
seen a koala in the wild.
- Dude, I wanna see a koala.
- They're extremely rare in the wild
because they're so hidden.
But, my house, we used to have these wasps
that flew around all the time.
- Fuck, how'd you get rid of wasps?
- You don't.
The last time I went home,
I remember I was like,
my dad was like, you know,
"Son, come and join me
for a beer on the balcony,
it's a nice day", and
I'm like, "Yeah, sure."
I walk out and there's like
20 wasps just flying around.
- 'Cause I had to-
- And I was like,
"Father, there are a lot of wasps
flying around your face right now."
And he's like, "Yeah, it's all right.
They won't sting you."
I was like, "Okay".
- Why do wasps exist?
Do they do anything good for anyone?
- No.
They are the dickheads of the internet.
Not the internet, the insect world.
- You can say that about
so many creatures though.
- But like, so a lot of creatures
don't actively try to be
dickheads and sting you.
And the thing is at least nature-
- Are you judging an animal's worth
based on how annoying it is to people?
- [Garnt] Kind of, kind of, yeah.
(all laugh)
- Fair enough.
- What do wasps do for nature?
Because, you know, bees, they make honey,
they pollinise flowers and you know what,
at least nature had the
decency to Nerf bees, you know?
They get one shot.
- One shot.
- That's like their nuclear option, man.
That's like they'll fight for their lives.
- This is how super villains are born?
(all laugh)
- It starts with wasps, Garnt,
what's the next step? Huh?
- [Garnt] Like I would be-
- People under six foot, is that the next?
- [Garnt] I would be happy-
- What the point of people under six foot?
They can't reach the
shelves I've designed.
- I would gladly be racist towards wasps.
(all laugh)
- All right, well that's an out of context
clip in the making,
I would gladly be racist, cut.
(all laugh)
- No 'cause-
- Garnt's the kind of guy,
where if he got a death note,
the first thing he'd write is wasp.
- Wasps.
- Just every wasp.
- Everything that annoys me.
- Like one by one, one by one,
by name, every single wasp.
- Is that a syntax error
for the death note?
It comes back, it's like,
"Sorry, did not spell correctly."
- Yeah, I should preface,
I actually have a phobia
of bees and wasps.
I dunno if I've ever talked about this.
- You have told us.
You got stung in the eye as a kid.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, I forgot.
- [Joey] Yeah. Okay, yeah.
I would have that, for sure.
- Yeah, but the thing is, I've grown,
even though I'm fucking
deadly scared of them,
I still in my heart,
I still understand why bees are a thing.
I think, you know, after
years of conditioning,
like bumble bees, they look kind of cute.
They look like furry and
big and they pollinise-
- They're chunky.
- Yeah, they're chunky.
- Oh, let's give them a hug.
Have you taken any steps
towards trying to
conquer you fear of bees?
- Erm, bees-
- Maybe we should do like a
fear factoresque kind of thing.
where we have a-
- What would the steps be though?
- Why don't we play
Dark Souls music, right?
Like, (hums tune) and then we bring out,
and Garnt, your punishment for
the "Trash Taste After Dark"
is that you have to put
your head in a box of bees.
(all laugh)
- What?
- What, is this fear factor?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Would you do that?
- If you told me, if...
Okay, here's the thing,
right, I'm an idiot.
If some guy came on, he's
probably, he's always Australian.
Cause on every single wildlife show
where there's a wildlife expert,
the fucker's always Australian.
- Of course.
- He'll come on and be like,
"Oh yeah, they won't sting you."
And then 10 seconds later,
you're like, (screams).
And he'll like, "Oh, you're
fine though. You're fine."
- You're gonna die, don't worry.
(all laugh)
It changes to, "Oh, you won't die."
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, no.
If some wildlife expert told me
that it's safe to do it, I'd do it.
- What, stick your head in a box of bees?
- Yeah.
- I would not do it.
You couldn't pay me to do that.
- That's a big fucking step.
I mean like, I dunno if-
- How much for you to put
your hand in a box of bees?
- For how long?
- How much you're willing to pay me?
- One minute.
- One minute?
What is the minimum price you'd do it for?
- I don't know.
- 10.
- I would gladly do it for like five.
- Five?
- Yeah, five Gs.
- Five Gs. Yeah, 10 G for me.
- Oh no, it would have to
be more than 10 for me.
I don't know, maybe.
Or maybe just for content.
(all laugh)
- For that sweet ad revenue, baby.
- That sweet ad revenue.
- If I'm just chilling in
my living room, and you,
"Connor, how much to put
your hand in a box of bees".
I'd be like, "Ah, five
grand" and then they do it.
But if it's for content,
I probably do it for free.
- I mean, here's the thing, right?
Because before, like when I was a kid,
I couldn't even look at...
I couldn't even look at videos of bees.
I'd see a bee and I'd literally scream
and run inside and shut the screen.
- So if we got a box of bees,
you would do it for content.
How do we get a box of bees?
- Maybe, maybe.
- Don't give the audience an idea.
- How do they do this on shows?
How do they get a box of bees?
- I go through phases where,
maybe out of a sense of morbid curiosity,
I look at bee cleaning
or bee videos on YouTube.
And just seeing these beekeepers
just fucking scooping
up these pile of bees.
And just them casually being like,
"Oh, you know, they're
very friendly today.
I've only been stung three times."
I'm like, you've been stung three times
and that's it, that's it?
I'd be fucking... one time
is more than enough for me.
- I wonder how many
times would you get stung
if your hand was in that box for a minute,
with like a hundred bees?
- I think if you just stay still-
- Nothing.
- Probably nothing.
- But if you're doing this...
- This is ignorant wilful, what is it?
- [Garnt] Wilful ignorance?
- Yeah, wilful ignorance, I think.
Yeah, I'm sure we could get some.
- Bees maybe, because bees
maybe, wasps, get the fuck out.
I'm coming here with a flame thrower.
- [Connor] Bees, bees, bees.
- If you come here with
wasps, 'cause like, I think-
- How about we put your hand in a box
with a feral hyena, Garnt?
What do you reckon? For a minute?
- For one minute.
- For one minute. We all win.
- For content. For content. (laughs)
- For content.
- I dunno, it's like, I've
also like been glad...
Have you ever seen a hornet as well?
- Yeah.
- Those are fucking terrifying.
I think I've seen one.
- We have the killer hornets here.
You have the killer hornets here.
- Yeah, those, I don't
wanna fuck with those.
Those are like scary.
- Those are scary.
- Yeah, especially, I
remember seeing the video
of just hornet...
it sounds like a fucking
anime fight or something.
It's like hornets versus
bees and it's the-
- Dude, that video's epic.
Where the bees surround it?
- Yeah, the bees surround it.
And it's not even like
a war, it's a massacre.
'Cause the hornet, like one hornet
takes down a fucking hundred
bees or something, and it's...
I feel like-
- No, no.
The bees fuck up the hornet.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- We've seen different videos
then, 'cause I've seen-
- It's two different fights.
(all laugh)
- I dunno which bee it
is, but there's videos
where there is a way
that they kill the hornet
by basically they all just
compact themselves on the hornet.
- Right.
- And they roll around
and they do it with such energy
that it actually just
burns the hornet alive.
- What, like through friction?
- Yeah, it kills the
hornet by being so hot.
- Holy shit.
- That's fucking metal.
- Japanese.
- Japanese honeybees.
- [Crew Member] Japanese honeybees.
- They kill the Japanese, they surround it
and they compact like a ball and they roll
and keep suffocating it and burning it.
- What the fuck?
- [Connor] It's so badass.
- What?
That is fucking badass.
- It's so cool.
I'm sure there'll be a clip
on the screen right now.
It's fucking cool, it's so cool.
Like nature sometimes is like-
- That just sounds like a Shonen power.
- I just love it that these
bees figured this out.
They're like, fuck it,
just throw ourselves at it.
- How the bees figure that out?
- I don't know, man.
- Fucking hell.
- Have you heard of friction?
We could use that.
- Yeah, because the only video I've seen
is where it's just these
bees, this hive of bees,
just fucking chilling, making honey.
Then these fucking group
of 10 hornets or something
just come on and start fucking
biting their heads off,
massacre this entire
hive and then fuck off.
I'm like, Jesus Christ.
(Connor hums)
- Where was that in "Bee Movie"?
(all laugh)
- Yeah, fucking nature can
be fucking metal sometimes.
'Cause I remember seeing this video,
not about bees, but I think it was ants.
And scientists were like...
they were studying fire ants
because fire ants have a way
when they're moving in a
group or have, they have...
How can I word this?
When they're, what do
you call a group of ants.
- A colony?
- Yeah, colony of ants,
the way they act and behave sometimes
can behave like a liquid
and sometimes can behave like a solid.
- This is certain ants, I think,
can do it, not all of them.
- Yeah, not all of them.
I think is it was fire ants.
- They can cross water
by bunching together.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And basically becoming
kind of like a pseudo solid.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then they can kind of like...
- Yeah, so they can have, these
ants can have, as a colony,
have properties of a liquid or a solid,
depending on the situation.
- That's so dope.
- And they were like,
scientists were literally studying them
to try and apply this
to like real life metals
and real life applications.
I'm just like, "That
sounds so fucking metal"
- Can humans become liquid
if we try hard enough?
(Joey laughs)
- I'm solid Joey now,
soon I'll be liquid Joey.
- I am solid Joey.
But no, yeah.
That's the weird nature videos
I've seen every now and again.
Did you guys watch a lot of nature videos?
- Oh yeah, I fucking love
nature documentaries.
- [Garnt] I think...
- I grew up watching...
'cause they used to
just do constant reruns
of every David Attenborough documentary.
- I suppose in fucking Australia,
they would have had loads.
- Oh yeah, we love that shit.
- Go outside and you'll
see your local kangaroo
fighting a koala bear.
- No, the only kangaroo club was the one
where the guy punched
the kangaroo in the face.
- Oh, that was a good one.
- That one was all over Australian
news for like two months.
- [Garnt] Yeah, I remember.
- He was saving his dog.
- What's that about? What's that like.
- The kangaroo was like...
- Yeah, the kangaroo-
- He had the dog.
- Yeah, he had his dog
in a grip, in like a vice group.
- How does that happen?
- I don't know.
The clip literally starts
with the guy in his truck,
just calling out to the dog being like,
"Oh no, fucking Terry",
or whatever the fuck his name was,
I don't remember what it was.
And he jumps out and the camera pans over
and this red kangaroo, like, you know,
beefy motherfucker, standing
like two meters tall
just has the dog in a grip like this.
And the dog's just like, "Help me."
It has the most like, help
face that I've ever seen.
And he squares up and the
kangaroo's fucking squaring up
and that's really dangerous
because one kick from this red kangaroo,
in the chest, that dude is dead.
A hundred percent.
- Right.
- But no, this guy's like the biggest
mega chat on the planet,
which just goes whack and
just socks him in the face.
And the kangaroo's like, "What the fuck?"
He looks around and he's like, "No".
He just jumps away.
And he saves the dog.
I think as well, the kangaroo
felt threatened by the dog,
I think, so the kangaroo also
tried to kick the dog as well.
So the dog could have died too.
- But what do kangaroo
eat? What do they eat?
- Grass.
- Are they herbivores?
- Yeah.
But they're also very-
- Pretty fucking strong for herbivores.
- But they're also extremely
territorial as well.
- Oh.
- Is the picture I've
seen of jacked kangaroos,
is that Photoshopped or is that real?
I could never tell if it...
I've seen it in memes.
- Some of them are real
and I'm sure some of them are overdone.
But red kangaroos,
which are like the biggest
breed of kangaroos,
they on average stand
like two meters tall.
- I mean Australia has the
most interesting wildlife.
- Yeah.
- I mean that's because it was Pangaea,
on its own for like hundreds
of thousands of years.
- Yeah.
- So all these weird animals.
- It was like one of the
first ones to break off.
- Yeah, so it's had hundreds
of thousands of years.
But that's also why
it's also super delicate
and why when they introduce foreign pests,
it completely fucked up Australia.
They have a rabbit problem.
You know about this,
do you know about this?
- Yeah.
But they can't kill the rabbits.
Do you know why?
- Why?
- Because people don't want
'em to kill the rabbits,
but the rabbits are
literally killing everything.
- Everyone's like, "Oh, the
bunnies are so cute though".
And farmers are like, "Er."
- They eat everything and
there's nothing left for the...
you know, 'cause rabbits are like insane.
They're so good at taking everything.
- Yeah.
- And fucking.
- Like the British.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(all laugh)
They literally, well,
I think it was brought
over by a British guy.
- Of course it was.
- Because the guy wanted to hunt rabbits
in Australia.
- In Australia.
- So he brought over some rabbits.
I could be incorrect on this.
And obviously rabbits are
very, very good at expanding.
And so they have a terrible problem
and they've been trying to, they had a...
they were gonna start culling
them and getting rid of them.
But obviously trying
to pass a thing saying,
"Hey, we're gonna murder
a million plus rabbits.
Is that cool with everyone?"
A lot of people are like,
"No, rabbits are so cute.
We can't get rid of rabbits."
But it's like, "But our wildlife is..."
"But, but rabbits are cute."
Brings up a really interesting question
of is it, you know, obviously-
- Just because it's cute.
- At which point do you count something
as a pest that needs control?
- Well, I think when it's actively-
- When it's actively fucking
up the natural wildlife.
- Yeah, that's the problem,
is that the delicate
ecosystem that Australia has,
because it's so susceptible
to pests and stuff.
I think the rabbit, which
just like went crazy
and so many of the natural-
- What does it fuck up?
What do the rabbits fuck up?
- Well, they eat everything.
They take everything.
- Because they eat all the food
that the natural animals are supposed to.
Or native, rather.
- Rabbits are only,
from what I understand,
they are only limited
by how much food there is.
They can breed and make
as many of themselves
as they need to.
It's just, is there enough food available?
And they're really good
at getting it as well.
So, what are those fucking tiny rats
with big ears and a tail, in Australia?
- Oh, Bilbies.
- Yeah, those things eat
shit compared to the rabbits.
The rabbits absolutely
cream them in everything.
And also rabbits, like
rabbits eat their own babies.
- Do they?
- Yeah. Google it.
- Do they actually?
- Do they?
- Yeah.
- That's metal as fuck.
(all laugh)
- [Crew Member] A lot of that
animals eat their babies.
- Rabbits don't give a fuck.
Everyone's like, "Oh,
rabbits are so cute."
Rabbits eat their fucking babies, bro.
Well, you gonna call something cute
when it's devouring its first born child.
- It's like, all right, if I eat this one,
I can just make another one.
- [Crew Member] They
do, but only sometimes.
- Yeah, sometimes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But, like...
- The fact that that's
even an option is nasty.
- I mean, let's be honest, humans are...
let's not pretend like
humans haven't done it.
All right, we're not great.
If we judge the whole species
by one or two rogue rabbits,
then maybe.
- Okay, the one thing that
doesn't make sense to me,
I guess.
- Okay.
- Is okay, rabbits are
fucking thriving in Australia.
They're beating the shit
out of Australian wildlife.
Why is it not a problem in the UK?
- Well-
- Because you guys
don't have enough native animals, maybe?
- Well, rabbits are,
as far as I understand,
they're native to the UK.
So the whole ecosystem in
the UK had been created
with rabbits being in
it for a very long time.
If I'm correct. Can you Google this?
- [Crew Member] Foxes.
- Foxes.
- Well, the foxes eat the rabbits, right?
- Yeah, you need to
have the balance, right?
- I'm just finding it funny
that rabbits can survive
fucking Australia,
where you look at a spider
wrong and you're fucking dead.
And then in the UK, what the?
In the UK, foxes are
like the biggest pussies
of the animal kingdom-
- Australia has a lot of
species that are like...
you know, you're playing
on the the easy server.
It's like-
- What?
- A lot of these, even though we know
Australia is like one of
these super scary animals
with these snakes and stuff,
they have a lot of species of animals
that can only survive in Australia.
- Yeah.
- And it's very delicate.
- Well like koalas, for
example, only eat eucalyptus
and a specific type of eucalyptus
that's grown only in Australia natively.
So that's why you don't
see koalas in the wildlife,
outside anywhere else because
they literally can't survive.
- In any other continent,
the animal probably wouldn't have evolved
to just eat one type of plant
that is very not popular.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- You would have to adapt. Go on, sir.
Yeah. So.
- Okay.
- But in Australia,
they're like, it's our
territory now, baby.
- If you introduce a species
it's a problem why these,
obviously people didn't
understand this in the 1900's.
We didn't fucking know what was going on.
They were like, "Just bring my pets over.
I'm sure it'll be fine."
- What I understand is that the argument
of why we shouldn't be
getting rid of these rabbits.
It's like, "Oh, they're so cute though."
Meanwhile, when the Australian
government was like,
"Eat the kangaroos, right now",
no one was like, "But they're so cute."
- Okay, this is also a
common thing with cats.
Cats are more often, a
very big pest in places.
People don't wanna get rid of cats
because people have pets, they have cats.
If the government is
like, " Hey, you at home,
are you okay with us
killing all of this animal?"
And you look down and you see
that animal staring at you,
that you've loved and named and fed,
and you know what I mean?
It's really hard and-
- So what you're saying is,
less people need to keep rabbits as pets.
(Garnt laughs)
- No, no, no.
- I understand both-
- To change the status quo.
- What he's saying, is
rabbits have way too good PR.
- [Connor] That is literally-
- That PR is too fucking good.
- They're like the McDonald's of animals.
They've got it down, right.
You can tell them that McDonald's
puts all the shit in their food,
It doesn't fucking matter.
People are gonna eat it.
It's like I understand both sides,
and I empathize with both.
I empathize with these poor people
who care about the natural
wildlife, who are like,
"We need to keep it the
way it was supposed to be."
I also understand why that
person with 10 rabbits at home
might not wanna have all of
the rabbit population culled.
I get both, right.
Also, another fun fact,
while we're on fun facts about animals.
- Go on.
- Did you know?
I love this.
I was watching an episode
of QI the other day
and they talking about this?
- Do you know why, for the longest time,
they never gave the
giant tortoise a genome,
like an official genome name.
- Why? What's a genome?
- You know how every name,
every animal has a Greek name.
- Oh, okay.
- Right.
- Do you know why they never
gave the giant turtle a name?
- No.
- They knew about this
animal for a very long time.
Right?
- Problem was-
- These are the motherfuckers
that can live like 300 years.
- Yeah, exactly.
Problem was people
couldn't stop eating them.
They never ever made it back.
- Oh, I did hear about this.
- What?
- Yeah.
Every time they tried
to ship the tortoise-
- People would just eat them.
- Yeah, it would never survive the journey
'cause they were too delicious.
(all laugh)
Apparently through the...
'cause we don't eat it anymore, obviously.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- [Crew Member] 'Cause there's none left.
- 'Cause there's none left,
they're an endangered species now, right?
- In the writing, right.
it is literally like the perfect storm
of unfortunate for the giant tortoise.
So, apparently, in all of the documents
left about the giant tortoise,
it tastes better than any meat.
It tastes better than lamb.
It tastes better than beef.
It tastes better than pork.
Everyone almost unanimously
agreed, who tried this meat,
agreed that it tasted better
than all of them, right.
- Damn, I wanna try it.
(all laugh)
- Right. Right.
Another unfortunate evolutional part
of the giant tortoise is that it also,
this is just so sad.
It evolved so that it could store
up to one gallon or one liter of water,
I can't remember which one it was.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Inside of its body, almost
perfectly like a sack.
So when you would eat it as a human,
there was almost perfectly
this one liter capsule.
- So basically, it came with a drink.
(all laugh)
- It came with a...
- It's like a meal.
- Imagine it, you've just had
this, you're living in this-
- It's just a survival pack.
- At the end of the day.
- You're living in the time
where beer was drank more than water,
because water was, more
often than not, poisonous.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was hard to get a
hold of in certain places.
So you had this animal
that tasted amazing.
That was this perfect kind of,
like it could store very easily.
It was very easy to eat.
- Yeah.
- Or a lot of the meat
was edible in it as well
and it had this one gallon sack of water
that you could just drink.
So sailors would, when
they would take them back,
they were like, "Well
fuck, we're gonna eat it."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because not only was
it delicious and amazing,
they also had a free gallon
of water they could drink.
So it never made it back.
- Wait, so does it have a genome now?
- It did, it did after
after many, many years,
it finally got one.
- Just, food.
- But it never survived the journey
back to the UK or something.
- Wow.
- Unfortunately, it could
never be classified.
- I just... (laughs)
That's just so good.
That's really fucked up,
but that's hilarious.
- Oh, that was really funny.
- Can you imagine it?
You're just on the boat,
and you're like, fuck.
- I just wanna imagine
the scientists waiting.
They're like, "All right,
I wanna see this animal
so I can figure it out."
They're like, "What do
you mean you ate it?"
- They're like, they're on the port back.
They're like, we're gonna bring back 10.
We're gonna eat nine.
We're gonna let one go back.
All right, we all agree, one can go back.
- We only need one to name it.
- And then that's like
one week left on the ship
and they're like, "Fuck, dude.
Remember that flambeed giant
tortoise we had, dude."
Ooh.
- It's looking kind of
delicious right now.
- I'm getting real parched.
(all laugh)
- Just makes me wonder how
good must it have tasted.
- Yeah, it must have been amazing.
They come back to port.
They're like, "All right,
we brought 10 back.
We got one, how many shells?
We got like one, two, three...
Fuck, we ate them all."
(all laugh)
What the fuck?
- Next trip guys, next trip.
This time we're gonna bring 11.
- The way they wrote about it,
was that it was so delicious that,
it sounded like they genuinely
just couldn't resist eating it.
But like, imagine it's that delicious.
We were like, "Boys, do you fancy
just going for a quick
voyage to the islands
to go and get some more giant tortoises."
And they just keep eating it every time.
I'd like to think it was that good
that they would go back
to go and get more.
- Me and the boys on the
way to get giant tortoises.
- [Connor] Oh. Oh, dude.
- It's an endangered species now, right?
It's an endangered species now, right?
- [Crew Member] It's extinct.
- It's... (laughs)
- Oh, I thought it was just endangered
- No, we fucked up.
- Okay, okay.
- [Crew Member] We ate all of them.
- So it's kind like the
Dodo as well, right?
- [Crew Member] I don't
think we ate the Dodo.
- But, I would rather it
was... okay, I'm not...
I don't want us to
extinct any animal, right.
But I would rather us extinct an animal
'cause it's too damn delicious,
not that we wanted its horn or something.
That feels so wasteful.
If we're like, "Dude,
we made an amazing stew
out of the giant tortoise",
part of me is like, "That's fucked up".
Okay, at least you used it.
- At which point do you think
natural selection should
just take its course?
- Right.
Okay, I'm just saying...
- Are you saying, it's your fault
for being born this delicious.
- I don't know, I don't know.
- He's got a point. He's got a point.
If this...why the fuck?
This animal just was so unfortunate
that it evolved to be the
perfect food for humans to eat.
- You fucked up in some way in evolution
by being super delicious.
- And having a free sack of clean water.
- I'm sorry, you kind of
are, you kind of are, right.
They just didn't survive, obviously.
- Again, every part of the
tortoise was also edible.
The marrow apparently was also
delicious in soups and stuff.
It was, every single part of
this fucker was delicious.
This tortoise had evolved somehow
to be so goddamn delicious.
I don't get it.
And I'm angry that I'm
never gonna get to try it.
- Yeah, I'm angry that I'm
never gonna try it now as well.
So, I mean, I'm more
angry that it's extinct
because I can't try it now.
(all laugh)
- Fuck it's feelings, I wanna eat it.
- [Garnt] Listen, listen, we care about-
- Can it be like the McRib or something,
just come back for a month.
- We care about nature or
something, all that bullshit
but you know, the delicious animal.
I mean, we've talked about
eating possible dinosaurs
and all the dinosaurs we might
not possibly be able to eat.
Where's the Jurassic Park episode
where they bring back a extinct animal
so they can just serve
it as a delicacy, right.
That's all I'm saying.
- We brought, the sign is like,
we brought back the T-Rex
because we heard flambeing
this shit, mm, so good.
- That's what Jurassic
Park would actually be.
It wouldn't be a... it
would be a restaurant.
It wouldn't be a theme park.
- It wouldn't be a theme
park, it would be...
'Cause like, come on, come on.
If you bring back an extinct animal,
there's gonna be that
one fucker who's like...
- Me, I'm gonna be that fucker.
- How do they taste?
Come on, there's gotta...
there's definitely gonna
be a dinosaur restaurant
somewhere in the world.
- Of course.
- I mean, it's, you know, the turtle,
it's unfortunate that it
was perfectly evolved to be-
- Yeah.
- To be eaten.
- I mean-
- The writing was on the wall.
- There are some animals
where I'm just like,
without humans you'd be fucking,
you'd be on your last legs.
(all laugh)
- We saved you. You should
grateful, snow leopard.
- How did pandas become
China's national animal, right?
Because, isn't it like panda's,
isn't it like they have to-
- They don't fuck.
- They do not fuck.
They just refuse to have
fucking have offspring and fuck.
And I'm just like, if you have an animal
that just does anything
that it possibly could
to willingly not fucking breed,
at which point do you just like,
maybe they just don't wanna exist anymore.
- They don't wanna exist anymore.
(all laugh)
What, the panda's just
like, we just wanna die.
Could you stop?
- Here's the problem
with us as humans when,
I think, it comes to us
with extinct animals.
The amount of shit we give
about saving an animal
is inherently tied to how cute it is.
That is such a...
I refuse to believe any other explanation.
- That is true.
- If you told us,
"Oh, we have to save this
one species of flounder",
people would be like, "Oh."
"I think we can live without a flounder."
- But it's delicious.
- Yeah, it's like, oh.
- There's two things people care about.
Is it delicious?
- And is it cute?
- Right, if a panda wasn't as
cute as it is, would we care?
- Probably not as much.
- Let's be honest.
We are so fucking biased.
All the animals we wanna save
are either cool as fuck or cute as fuck.
- That is true.
- Think about it.
Think of an animal off top of the head
that people are trying to help,
like you see campaigns about and stuff,
where the animal isn't cute or cool.
- I mean, I don't know how,
The most endangered
species I know are pandas.
- [Connor] Cute.
- Tigers, maybe?
- Name an extinct animals,
that are going extinct.
- Tigers.
- Cool.
- Cool, yeah.
I mean, it's just any
animal with good PR, right?
- That's it.
But to get good PR, you
need to be cute, right?
- Cute or like badass.
- Like, if a species
of snake was dying out
yeah, those snake people
online would, oh, no.
- Snake people.
- You know who I'm talking about,
but most people wouldn't
give a shit, let's be honest.
You're not gonna see the
fundraisers about it.
I'm just being honest, that's how we are.
We're so fucking biased as humans.
We love to be like, oh
yeah, save all the animals,
except the ugly ones.
Fuck 'em, they can die.
- Unless they're like exceptionally ugly,
like the blob fish where
it just becomes a meme,
then it's like, well now we gotta save it
because look at this motherfucker.
- Now it's fugly, now it's just great.
- Now it's like, it's so ugly, it's cute.
- Now I'm fucking cheering for it
because it's the fucking underdog.
Now look at it. No-one's
gonna cheer for that.
So now I'm gonna cheer for that.
- [Joey] He's doing his best.
- We're like, oh, we need
to save the tooth fish.
And it's just a fish that
is just like, literally,
razor blades and like no eyes or face.
- They're like, well, no
one gives a fuck if it dies.
I mean, I... don't get me wrong.
I'm sure the scientists
who spend their life
researching these stuff will be very sad,
but the general population doesn't care
and let's not pretend like we do.
We don't, we don't, let's not...
- No, we don't.
- We only care when it's already happened.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I guess so.
I mean, animals have been going extinct
for the entire history of nature itself.
- I'm not saying we should
just let them go extinct.
- No, no, no, I'm not saying that.
I'm saying I feel like...
- Fuck 'em.
- I feel like we should
try to preserve nature
as much as we can.
- Of course.
- But you know.
- We're not gonna be like,
weak mindset, see ya.
- What are we, the board
meeting of the fucking "Lorax"?
What is this?
I think we should get
rid of all the plants,
make more museums.
We need more water parks.
Fuck them, fuck the planet.
- I mean, if humans
have had a direct effect
on making this animal extinct,
I think, yeah, we should
take responsibility.
We should be like, okay, yeah,
we kind of fucked up
their entire environment,
their entire habitat.
Let's try not to do that again,
unless they're delicious of course.
- You think rabbits have this meeting?
(all laugh)
Should we start fucking?
Does seem like we're taking
over a lot of things.
- He's enjoying it too much.
- Consume, consume, fuck, consume.
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- [Connor] Watching Netflix
without using ExpressVPN
is like buying tickets to
a Taylor Swift concert,
but only being able to
watch the opening act.
- That's horrible.
- I wanna see Taylor.
- As you know, a lot of content
on Netflix is region locked.
Luckily we get all the anime,
but I'm missing a lot of
good old British TV shows.
But thanks to ExpressVPN,
that's a problem of the past.
- [Joey] Because
ExpressVPN lets you change
your online location to wherever you want.
Control where you want Netflix
or other streaming websites
to think you're located and boom,
all of those libraries will
be open to you like that.
- I actually use ExpressVPN quite often.
Just one tap on the app.
It's very easy.
- Very easy.
- It's very easy.
- I dunno what else there is to say.
It's easy.
You can pick any country you want.
And if you wanna change your
region for whatever reason,
be it content or if you're shopping,
buying tickets for stuff.
You know, you sometimes
get cheaper flights.
So yeah, it's really easy to use.
- So, what are you waiting for?
Be smart.
Stop paying full prices
for streaming services
and only getting a
fraction of their content.
Get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
That's expressvpn.com/trashtaste
to get an extra three months
of ExpressVPN for free.
- Back to the episode.
- Have you ever had to clear out
wasp infestation or whatever.
- Yeah.
It sucks.
- What's the process around that.
- A broom and running shoes?
- Well, in the UK, I think
you just call a specialist.
- Yeah.
- But I think a lot of people
just take matters into their own hands.
- Yeah, we just take
matters into our own hands.
- Yeah, because I know,
I've had to see Sydney's
dad deal with a wasp nest,
a wasp nest being just newly formed.
And even that was just
like, I am standing behind,
it's like six foot of bulletproof glass
while I'm watching you do this because I-
- How did he deal with
it? Did he shoot it?
(all laugh)
That's the most American thing.
Not on my property.
- Bang.
- Honey, get the shotgun.
- He had a broom, he had a broom as well.
But yeah, he had a shotgun just in case.
- There is no good reason to own an M16
unless there's a wasp.
- Yeah. I have seen-
- I'm gonna shoot them down one at a time.
- I seen a video on YouTube of Americans
and I think they were Texans
getting rid of wasps nest with a shotgun
and it went exactly how you think it went.
- Oh, shit.
(Joey imitates shooting)
Wasps immediately come and attack.
- Yeah.
Is there any fucking
animals that terrify you,
that you'd see and you're
like, (blows raspberry)
- I think Australia's just
conditioned me to be like,
as long as it doesn't kill me,
I'm not really afraid of it.
- There's no one particular animal or bug
that scares me the most.
If there's a deer or
a bear in front of me,
yeah, I'm gonna be scared.
We've already spoke about this.
Yeah, we have.
- Scared.
- It's not so much me being
scared of a lot of animals,
it's just being creeped
out or cautious about them.
I'm not scared of a cockroach,
but I'm not like, "Ooh
yay, little cockroach."
You know, I don't love it.
- Yeah, you know what's...
Okay, one bug, not scary.
Like 50 bugs together,
freaks me the fuck out.
- Ah.
- Yeah, I'm actually the same.
Like, I fucking hate spiders.
I mean, only a few people
don't hate spiders,
but I actually prefer,
the bigger the spider is,
the more comforting it is for me
because at least I can see it.
It never leaves my view.
- Easier to kill.
- Right.
- It is, it's like...
- Get the shotgun.
- A larger hit box.
(all laugh)
- Literally, it's got like
a larger hit box, right.
In case I wanna do something.
Those fucking small
spiders that scurry about,
those are the ones that
fucking keep me up at night.
And I dunno why, I dunno why.
- It's the one thing I
don't miss about the UK.
I had a lot of spiders
in my house in Wales.
- Are any of them poisonous there?
- No, no, no, you just don't wanna see,
like when they go under your
bed and you've lost them.
- Weak mindset. (laughs)
- It does suck when you see a
spider go underneath your bed
and you're like, I'm dead.
- Oh no, the worst one
is when you're sleeping
and you see it on the ceiling
and you blink and it's just disappeared.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've had like loads of mice
and rat problems in the UK.
- Yeah.
- Have I told you about that?
- No. Actually I think you have.
- I think so.
- I've had rats in Swansea
and I had mice in London.
- Right, what's the difference
between a mouse and rat?
- Oh, you know the difference.
- Rat is like a huge mouse.
- Rats are like, well
they're massive, dude.
They're fucking disgusting.
Rats are like the mega Chads.
- Okay.
- And the mice is just like civilians.
- Mice aren't that scary
but mice are so fast.
- Rats are fast.
- Mice move at like the
fucking speed of light though.
And also the thing that sucks about mice
is that they can... no
gap is too small for mice.
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- They can fit through anything.
So they would go under the door,
even though the clearance is like this,
they would like squeeze underneath.
- They turn into a liquid form.
- Literally, literally dude.
I remember 'cause we were...
it was so funny 'cause
this maisonette in London
that was created, it was being touted
as being rat and mouse proof.
That was the whole point
behind the building.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- And the landlord was extremely furious
when I told him about it.
I was like, "Yeah man, oh, we got mice."
And he's like, "What?
I bought this place specifically
'cause I was told that
it couldn't have mice."
I'm like, "Well we got mice". And so he-
- How do you make a
place mouse and rat free?
- It's not possible. I
don't think it's possible.
And so we had these mice
and they always came out at night.
I dunno if that's normal.
- Yeah.
- I never saw them during the day, but-
- Are they nocturnal?
- I dunno, it was horrible though
'cause I'd be in my bed watching Netflix.
TV's there, door is here
and I'd just see a shadow.
(imitates air whooshing)
- Oh shit.
- In my room.
- Yeah, I've had that before.
- And I was like, what the fuck?
- That's so weird, we don't
get mice and rats in Australia.
- Might be too hot.
- I don't know.
- Well I think it's 'cause all the snakes
are fucking eating them.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- They get like fucked by
snakes and stuff like that.
- Yeah, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And cats and stuff.
We tried all this expensive
stuff for killing them.
In the end, the thing that
killed them the most was just-
- Mouse trap?
- The basic Amazon mouse trap.
It would clap their cheese.
- Don't fix something
that's not broken, right?
- I think the poison killed some of them,
but we ended up just
needing to like clog it.
But the thing is, they
chew through everything.
- Yeah.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- No matter what you
clog it with, they just,
they get through it.
Like in New York, the rats
can chew through concrete.
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- Holy shit.
- Little by little, right?
- Insane, it's insane.
- The one pest that-
- That's some Shawshank shit.
- Yeah, the one pest that terrifies me,
of ever getting, is termites.
I've never known anyone with termites.
- Oh, we had termites.
- It's not really a problem
unless you have a wood house,
though, isn't it?
- Yeah yeah, yeah, 'cause
at my parents' place
had a termite infestation and it was scary
because it's like, oh the
house might come down.
- It's the one of the few pests that,
if you have it in your house,
and under the right conditions,
it could just kill you.
Right, because you-
- Yeah, 'cause wooden houses
in Australia mainly, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- So yeah.
- How'd you deal with termites,
like what's the process around
getting rid of termites?
- When it comes to termites,
you just have to call
a specialist for that.
- Don't they just like gas the place?
- Pretty much. They like
smoke it out basically.
- Right?
- Yeah, we had a termite,
it wasn't a massive
infestation, but we were like,
yeah, we should probably
get rid of these now
because if they expand, yeah,
the house is gonna come down.
- Yeah.
- Like, so fuck that.
- That's fucking terrifying.
- It's so scary.
- That's so sick that when they do that,
like when they just put
gas all in the house.
- Yeah.
- I find that so cool.
- Well, why?
- Why is that cool?
- It's like, wow, they
just put like a tent
over the house and gas it.
I'm like, that's so badass.
Who thought, "Oh, we
gotta kill these rats.
Oh, Oh we gotta use these rat poison."
And the guy's like, "Hold up.
Boys, what if we gas the whole house."
- What if we nuke the house?
- And I'm like, the first
time someone suggested that
someone must been like, you're crazy.
Like, no, no, hold on.
What if we put a big tent,
a comically large tent around the house.
Someone's like, you're a genius.
Let's try it.
- How else are they gonna
get rid of thousands
of tiny insects just living
in every single crevice.
- They're not gonna be like...
- You're gonna be like,
well it's either like the
tent or the flame thrower.
And I'm like, before we
get the flame thrower out,
maybe we should throw out a tent, maybe.
- I think the one job on earth,
sort of somewhat related to this,
not dealing with getting
rid of bugs and stuff, but.
You know people who clean houses
after people have died.
- Yeah.
That's the one job I
don't think I could do.
- Oh, it depends how horribly they die.
- Yeah.
- Well, 'cause normally, you
know, when you get older,
you struggle to take care of yourself,
so the house gets really
like, you know, fucked.
And I saw one on Japan, so
depressing and it's just like-
- No, it happens very often in Japan.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
And they go in and they're just like,
well, we're just gonna take
all this guy's possessions
and trash them and stuff.
It's like, "Oh, oh, don't
break my heart, dude.
Just go into someone's
house trying to figure out,
what their life was and
stuff, I couldn't do it.
- Oh, I mean, I guess, I mean like.
- You're like, oh, I don't give a fuck.
Bring in the trash truck.
- I thought you meant people
who had been brutally
murdered or something.
- Yeah, that's what I thought.
- I was like, yeah,
that's a pretty bad job.
- I mean, that's probably one part of it,
but what if you're a guy who
couldn't take care of yourself,
you're like 70 and you know,
maybe you couldn't make it
to the toilet and stuff.
- I don't know, I feel like-
- And the room smells-
- Like you shit yourself.
- Well yeah, it happens, it happens.
- Yeah, of course.
I mean, I think that'd be like a fine job.
I mean, it's-
- What? Can't say I'll do it.
Gimme a tenner.
- I mean, it's not a pleasant job,
but I feel like it's...
- Would it not freak you out,
just knowing that someone was there,
and living there, like a week ago.
That'll freak me out.
- I think you'd get pretty numb
to it after a while, though.
- Dunno.
- I mean,
I feel like cleaning
out all of their stuff,
you'd just be like, "Oh,
this is someone's legacy.
This is someone's entire life".
Why would that freak you out?
- I dunno, just trying to
figure out what happened?
Like, what was their life like?
- Maybe that wouldn't, I think
that's super interesting.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You get a peak into someone's...
not saying this is like a
glorious job or something,
but I think, if someone died peacefully
of old age or something and
you're cleaning their house,
I think that would be a
really interesting way
to really piece together
what kind of person they are-
- I'm think, unfortunately,
in the modern era,
we have this peaceful ignorance
that we think that a lot of
deaths are this pleasant.
He passed away with
his friends and family.
Especially in Japan and stuff.
It's like, "No, Tanaka San
died age 90 in his apartment
and his family hadn't
seen him in five years
and he doesn't have any friends.
- And he's just a skeleton now.
- And it's yeah-
- It happens.
- 'Cause the video was following
this guy, that I watched,
and he was cleaning it
out and he was like,
"Yep, it looks like he
tried to make some food
right before he passed,
but he wasn't able to."
And it's like, "Oh".
- Heartbreaking, yeah.
- Man just wanted a curry, dude.
We all deserve that, we all
deserve just a nice meal.
- Before the curry.
- Wait, so how did they die then?
- Well, you know, if you
are getting really old
and you're not able to make
it to the toilet and stuff
and you can barely get outta bed
and no one's there to help you.
You know, it can be really fucked.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- You know, one day your
heart could just be like,
"I don't think so", and
then just stop, you know?
- Wow. Yeah.
- I mean, I think there are worse ways
to pass away than that.
They died in their home and you know,
I think that would be something
where a lot of people wish to pass away.
- I think a worst job is the people
who have to clean up
after train accidents.
- Yeah, that would be traumatic for you.
- That would suck ass.
- Like to me, if I knew
a guy died peacefully,
peacefully of old age in their own house,
I'm like, you know what?
Death is never a nice thing,
but if there was a way
that I would want to go
it would be like that, you know.
Just nice and peaceful in
the comfort of my own home.
- Just like very quietly, you know,
just like reflecting
on that person's life.
Meanwhile, it's like, oh cool.
This guy jumped in front of a train.
I have to pick up his
fucking pieces of his skull.
You know, I would much
rather do the house job
than the other one.
- I know.
I remember I stayed at an Airbnb once
and the guy running this Airbnb
was this old Japanese guy.
He was in his seventies or something.
And he was showing us, you know,
giving us a tour around the house.
And it's a bit morbid actually,
but just one block away from
the house was a graveyard.
Right?
- Oh yeah.
- And we had to walk
through this graveyard
to get to his house, right.
And he pauses at one of the graves
and he talks about, oh, this is,
you know, my dad's here,
my granddad is here
and I'm gonna be right there.
And me and Sydney go.
- He's always prepared. He's prepared.
- Cool.
How do you react to that?
How'd you react to, I got
an old guy being like,
yeah, I'm gonna be there in a few years.
I'm like-
- Why wait, let's do it now.
(all laugh)
Hoe came outta nowhere.
- But I mean, I can't
even begin to empathize
what my thoughts would
be like at that age.
At what point do you just
accept your own mortality-
- [Joey] I think that's kind of badass.
- Come to terms with it,
come to peace with it.
- I think it's kind of badass though,
to be like, just kind of facing reality
and being like, you know
what, I'm gonna be there soon.
I'm just gonna enjoy life,
while I still have it,
kind of thing, you know?
- Yeah.
- He's pre-ordering.
(Garnt laughs)
He pre-ordered his gravestone.
- He pre-ordered the gravestone.
- Pre-ordered death.
- He had the space, and everything.
I was just like, "Oh fuck."
To me, as a young guy,
to me as a guy in his thirties,
I was like, "Dude, that's
a bit morbid to me."
But I mean, I don't know,
at that age, I dunno how I'd feel.
- Well, people in Japan
like everything planned out.
- That's true.
- They like everything to be predictable.
They're like, "I wanna know when I'm dying
so I can fucking figure out how
many crochets I need to do."
- Okay, at which age
would you ever consider
getting life insurance?
Right, 'cause, okay.
- Isn't it when you get
kids you're supposed to.
- Yeah, usually.
- Or like writing a will?
Right.
- Right.
It's something you never
really think about.
- But don't they say that
you should write a will
in your 20's?
- Yeah, I've wanted to,
I've been meaning to.
- We're at that age group
where we should have a will already.
- Well, okay, okay. Here's the thing,
I think it's when you have something.
You know, we're quite
successful, we've done well.
And so if you have some savings
that could be of great help
to your family members or something.
Fuck the government.
Don't give it to them.
Make sure you know who in
your family who gets it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah yeah.
So I think if you have anything
worth giving to your
family that is significant,
you should do a will at any age.
You know, God forbid
something happens, but-
- Yeah, God forbid.
- And to my sister, I give my
entire body pillow collection.
Nothing else.
Do not touch the bank money.
- Who am I giving my YouTube channel to?
(all laugh)
I'm literally giving away clout.
Who wants the clout on my YouTube channel.
- I have already decided that I want my,
the reading of my will
to be a comical endeavor.
So I'm gonna add the most
stupid items to my will
and be extremely specific
with instructions
just to get a good laugh from the grave.
- Yeah, I dunno because I don't
have any brothers or sisters
and I would hope that I
pass away after my parents,
and I don't have any kids right now.
So, at this point, I'm just like,
when is there, if that
like awkward conversation
or that awkward realization to be like,
I should write a will or I
should look into life insurance
because, I don't know...
I dunno about your parents,
but I remember a few years ago,
my parents told me that they
had started writing their wills
and I'm just like, "Mom, Dad,
I don't wanna think about that right now.
Just don't tell me, I don't wanna...
I acknowledge it, but at the same time,
I don't want to hear about."
- I mean, my dad just
used to meme his will
all the time growing up.
If I ever did a good deed,
my dad would be like,
"I'm adding that to the will."
(all laugh)
"You get an extra item on my will".
It's like, "Yes."
And my sister would be
like, "What the fuck"?
- It's like a fucking competition.
Who wants the house in the
will? Who's it gonna be?
- Yeah, 'cause I told the story
of how I gave my dad, my
dad wanted a car engine.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And he's like, "Son, the
entire record collection
that I have, was to your sister,
but now it's under your name now."
I was like, "Yes'.
- I'd like to think your dad
doesn't even have a will.
He's just making shit up.
- He making it up.
- He's just saying shit as he goes along.
- Probably, but yeah, I
remember I read somewhere.
I think I was on a Japanese program
that they recommend that you
should just write a will,
as soon as you just have awareness.
- I think it's pretty cheap.
I think any document and then
you get it witnessed, I think?
- Yeah.
- I don't think it's that complicated.
I think it's just going
out of your way to be like,
"Hey, I'm going to write about the moment
after I've passed away and
who gets my belongings".
And before you think to
yourself and you're like,
"I don't have any belongings
worth giving away to begin with,
why would I write a will?"
- Well, my JuJu collection
needs to go somewhere.
- Who would you give that to?
Who would you give that to?
Would you trust one of
your family members to it?
- I would trust the boys
with my JuJu figures.
I'd like to think you'd keep onto them.
- Thank you very much.
- You'd treat them well.
- You would-
- Definitely not recently, man.
- You can resell it if you want.
(all laugh)
I better get good prowess, it's my JuJu.
- Like on your death bed, I'll be like,
"Could you just like quickly sign these."
- Hopefully my name won't
be worthless at that point.
Maybe it'll worth something. I don't know.
- How do you go about...
like what is the structure
of writing a will though?
That's what I've always wanted to know.
Do you write it like a
novel or like a letter?
- I think you can be as-
- Can you write it like a poem?
- I think you can be as
playful as you want with it.
You ever thought about doing a video will?
- A video... Yeah.
- What's up guys? Welcome to my will.
So I'm dead.
- Is that like the new
YouTuber fucking trend?
We've had apology
videos, now we just have-
- Make sure to subscribe. Just kidding.
You're not gonna get
another video after this.
- You've heard of,
I made this video five
years ago and uploaded it.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- Get ready for, I made
this video when I was alive
and you can play it when I die.
(all laugh)
I think that would be fucking cool.
- Yeah.
- I think that would be cool.
- Kind of like, so if you're
watching this video, I'm dead.
- But also the payoff might not work
if YouTube doesn't exist in like 60 years.
- Or it's probably gonna
be like age restricted
and fucking banned off YouTube.
Imagine that, someone
dies of a terminal cancer.
- You can play a video of
a dead person on YouTube.
- Well, I mean...
- It's not you showing the
fucking footage of you dying.
- I mean the...
- It's like me now, age
20, I record something.
I'm like, "This is to be played..."
Not me like, "Bye guys." Boom.
It's not that, it's...
- I mean, the only closest
thing I could think of
was the unfortunate thing
of what happened with Etika.
And that got removed by YouTube.
So, I don't know, we've
never had it before,
so I guess we've never had
like a precedent before,
like what would happen-
- Well, there's YouTubers who have died
and their video's still up.
I think that was a special circumstance.
- But, has there been a
YouTuber who has recorded their,
like a goodbye video?
- Right before they died?
- No, no, no, like a goodbye video
that would be uploaded postmortem.
Does that make sense?
- Without, okay, can I
ask a morbid question?
Are you asking that without the intention
of then doing something very sinister?
- Yeah, without the intention.
Let's say they have a
terminal illness or something.
- Oh yes, there is.
- There has been?
- There is.
- I'm sure there has been.
- There was a... it's a powerful watch.
- I don't think I could,
I don't think I have
the heart to watch that.
- Yeah, I don't think I could watch that.
- The guy was logging his cancer journey.
I forgot the name.
I wish I knew the name off by heart,
but it's hard to watch 'cause-
- Yeah.
- You know, he's doing well at some points
and then it's unfortunately,
it takes a turn for the worst.
- Yeah.
- And the last few videos
he uploads are very painful.
He's in the hospice and-
- Oh God.
- And you know, it's really...
I think that it was very rare
that we had footage of
watching that, but yeah,
he was uploading videos and
he unfortunately passed away,
but all the videos are there
and his whole journey's there
and it's very inspiring.
- But how cool is it that at least
all of that is now documented forever.
And that's just out
there for people to watch
and be inspired by.
- I can imagine that a lot of people
have found comfort with it.
I mean, yeah, it's hard to watch.
- Yeah.
- I don't think I could.
- This is going on a tangent
because we are talking
about terminal illnesses
and stuff like that.
- Right.
- Do you feel like, watching that,
watching something like
that happen in your eyes,
in front of your eyes, do you feel like,
with how awful that situation is,
that seeing that kind of thing
portrayed in media so often
has kind of like desensitized
or desensitized you
to like how awful that is in reality,
just because, you know, the cancer patient
or someone dying of cancer has been used
as such a common writing
trope in every sad anime film
and just every sad plot point in general.
- Yeah. I mean, it's...
I guess, until you experience it, right?
- Yeah.
- And it's someone close
to you or even yourself,
you'd experience it, I
think it's impossible
to portray it in an authentic way.
- I think though, just the sole fact that,
that trope has been used
so many times in fiction
and yet it still continues to draw emotion
out of the viewer or the
listener, whatever it is.
- Yeah.
- Stories about the main character
has a terminal illness, slowly dying,
and it shows all of that.
First time you consume anything like that,
99% of people will be very
emotional, you know, cry.
But it's interesting how you could watch
10 different shows like that,
and you'd probably still
cry on the 10th one as well.
So I think, even though it's
been overused in fiction,
I think just that is so
powerful and potent enough
that it'll just continue to
evoke some kind of emotion.
Let alone if you yourself
experience that shit.
That just adds onto it, I feel.
- Yeah.
- And I'm sure,
some people would be
desensitized to it, sure.
You know?
- Yeah.
- But I think at the end of the day,
there's a reason why writers
still use that trope.
- I guess for me, I went
through a weird experience
where I had seen so
many stories like this,
that there was a point where I
got desensitized to the media
where I was just like,
"Oh, it's a character dying
because of a terminal illness."
- [Joey] Yeah yeah, yeah.
- And then I unfortunately experienced
a family member passing away
because of something like
this and it was just like,
it definitely grounded me
in a way that I never...
not that I never thought I would,
it just put things into
perspective for me.
And it just, I don't know.
I haven't, since that has happened,
I've actively avoided
any stories around that
because it seems way more real to me.
So I dunno how I would react to that.
Part of the reason, for example,
that I couldn't watch "Clannad", right,
or I couldn't finish "Clannad"
was because at the time I was watching it,
it just felt like cry porn, right?
It just felt like cry porn
where I was so disconnected,
disconnected with what
was happening on screen,
because I'm just like,
this is Key just trying to make me cry.
You know, he's trying to make me cry.
But yeah, I dunno if I had a point.
I dunno if I would react differently
to watching those types of media
now that I have grown up
and have more experience
about the real events that, I guess,
influence stories like this.
- [Joey] Mm.
- And if I would still feel the same way,
or if I would still be desensitized,
because it is a fictional story
that has been told many, many, many times.
- I think when it gets
to that point, though,
it just revolves around how well written
those stories and characters are.
- That's true, that's true.
- There are so many stories
where they use that trope.
but you're just like,
"Okay, I know I'm supposed to feel sad
for this character right now,
but the writing is so mediocre
that it hasn't given me
enough emotional storage
for me to care about this character.
- That's true, that's true.
- I think it's impossible to replicate
the feeling of going
through it in real life,
just because no matter
how good the writing is,
'cause you know, you're talking about,
let's say it's a movie.
- Yeah.
- He tries to do it in two hours,
what would take essentially
a lifetime to build up?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- The reason it's so
crippling in real life
and it hurts so much,
is because if it's your
friend and it happens at 20.
It's like, alright, well you have 20 years
of being their friend.
And now it feels like it's being robbed.
So I feel like it's almost impossible
to portray it in a way that
will give you the same emotion.
I think it can give you a sense of empathy
in a very deep way,
but nowhere near can it
compare to the feeling
that you might feel if you go through it?
I think.
- Yeah.
- Well, I think one of
the biggest, not issues,
but one of the biggest hurdles
between communicating your experiences
to an audience member or to someone
who hasn't experienced
the same thing as you,
is that there is such a massive difference
between sympathy and empathy.
There'll be people I talk to
and they talk about their experiences
and I can definitely sympathize
with the emotion that they're feeling,
but there's also like...
do you guys ever feel a
connection with someone
who has actually shared the
same experience with you,
the same emotional experience with you?
There's a connection there
when you share that experience
that cannot be replicated
no matter how much other people
will try to understand you
and try to understand your feelings
and everything like that.
There is a feeling that
cannot be replicated
without the same empathy.
To me there's something special
about being able to
communicate that empathy
through fictional media. Right?
'Cause there are some
times where I watch a film
and I feel something that's not just,
"Hey, you should cry
or you should feel this
because this character went through that.
It's wow, I really feel
like an actual connection
with the creator now
because he's portraying an emotion
that I know is impossible to depict
unless you have been through
that exact experience.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I'm trying to feel,
I'm trying to think of
when was the latest time,
I mean off the top of my head,
I think of "Evangelion", right,
why I have such a close,
emotional connection to that.
And it's so weird for me with "Ava"
because I've watched "Ava"
in several stages of my life.
And the reason it's the
most important for me
was because there was a point
where I felt like I was going through
the exact same emotions the creator was,
and this is going on a complete
fucking tangent, by the way.
And yeah, I guess to me, that's why,
going on a different tangent,
that's why media is such
a big part of my life
and why I'm a fucking
anime YouTuber, I guess,
is because, I guess, that's
what I search for in media,
which is not just to be entertained,
but this connection with
a person and a creator.
And that's why I try to make content.
And I dunno where to go
from there, but that was-
- Thank you for coming to my Ted Talk.
- Thank you for coming
to my Ted Talk. Wow.
I guess this is where you go
from talking about people
dying from cancer, right?
Where do you go from here?
- Yeah, I dunno.
It's tough because I think the one emotion
that I personally feel
when it comes to real life
situations and stuff like that,
it's not even like...
'cause you know, when
you're watching media
that revolves around a
death of a character,
in any situation, most
people think of sadness.
You know, like a depression
or some rooted emotion.
People who have experienced,
at least for me,
when I experience a
real death that happened
you don't feel anything.
It's like you feel empty.
- Yeah.
- And I think this feeling of emptiness
is extremely difficult
to portray in fiction.
Because it's like, how do you try to show
or evoke an emotion
that is not an emotion?
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
'Cause I remember when one of
my friends from high school,
he unfortunately passed away very suddenly
from an illness.
- [Garnt] Right.
- You know, I had never experienced that.
That was the first time
I had experienced death
in a close, like a real
death in a close vicinity.
- [Garnt] Yep.
- And it was so weird because you know,
media and people who
haven't experienced that
would lead you to believe
that you go to a funeral.
- Yeah.
- And everyone's crying.
Yeah.
- And everyone's sad.
And I thought I was the weird one
because I didn't cry at his funeral.
And I was like, "Am I weird?
Am I being desensitized?"
I should be sad. I should be crying.
I should be grieving, you
know, all that kind of stuff.
And not to say that I wasn't.
But I think because I'd never experienced
anything like that before.
That's when I realized I was
like, "Oh, I'm feeling empty."
Because that, it's beyond
sadness. It's beyond grief.
And it was almost this weird thing
where I didn't start
crying about his death
until I got home.
- [Garnt] That was-
- And that's when it hit.
- That was the exact same experience
I had with my grandma as well.
At the funeral, I was just like,
"Am I broken? Am I a broken human being?"
I feel nothing.
- Yeah, it's like, I
should be crying right now.
You hear back on like, you know,
I was hearing back on my friend's life
and hearing speeches from
my classmates and whatnot.
And I was just like, "Why am
I not crying? Am I weird?"
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then it's like, you
grieve, everyone's sad.
And then I went home and I remember,
I went into my room and I lay on the bed
and then I just broke down crying.
And it's like, "Oh, that's
what that feeling is."
And it's like,
I personally have never
seen a piece of fiction
that can properly evoke that emotion.
Like it's, I don't
know, it's weird to say.
It's not like it's faking an emotion
or anything like that,
when it comes to fiction.
I wouldn't say it's like...
it's not the correct emotion.
- [Garnt] Yeah. I feel.
- And I think that's just because
it's just so incredibly difficult
to show that real emotion,
especially when it's with
a bunch of characters
that you didn't spend your entire
fucking high school life with.
- Exactly, so like personal question.
What's the most you've ever cried
to a piece of fiction at all?
- The most?
- Yeah.
- Probably the second half
of "Clannad: After Story"
The last six episodes, I was like...
Episode 14, 15, I'm
obviously not gonna spoil it.
- [Garnt] Yeah. (laughs)
- Around episode 14, 15
of "Clannad: After Story"
something happens, and it's
like, you break down crying.
And you think to yourself,
"Okay, it's all out of my system."
And then the next episode starts
and it's just like, fuck man, why?
And then it's just that,
for the rest of the
episodes until it's over,
and you're just a fucking mess.
- I just cry at everything.
A lot of (indistinct), stuff
that isn't even sad, I cry.
- Like what?
- I don't know.
Becky will be fighting,
and I'll hear my name
and I'll just start crying.
(both laugh)
Yeah, it depends on my mood, right.
Some days I'm like a
fucking rock and it's like,
it could be like the worst
thing on earth and I'll be like.
- It's really weird
'cause I've found myself,
and I think this is healthy
because I found myself more easily crying
towards pieces of media and
fictional pieces of media
now than I did like five-
- Oh God, yeah.
- Five years ago?
- I cry at everything.
- Yeah.
And I thing the one that
broke the camels back
was like, "Anohana".
- I cried a lot at "Anohana".
- Yeah.
- I think before "Anohana",
I don't think I had ever
cried watching an anime.
I'm trying to think back.
- For me it was weird.
It's like very early on when
I was watching a lot of anime,
'cause I think I first cried at "Clannad"
and then it was just like
a chain reaction of like...
and then I watched "Anohana"
and then I watched "Air"
and then I watch all these
shows that made you cry.
- [Garnt] Yeah yeah, yeah.
- And then for a while I had
this blank period where I-
- It's 'cause you exhausted yourself.
- Maybe, and then the one
that broke the camels back
for me was "Maquia".
- "Maquia", ah.
- "Angel Beats" made me cry a lot.
- "Angel Beats" made me
cry, but I didn't cry.
There was so many sad shows
that people would like cry.
I didn't cry at the end
of "Your lie in April",
even though a lot of people did.
- I didn't either.
- I don't know, and I was like,
"Am I weird for thinking that?
Am I just like overexposed
to this kind of media?"
And then I watched "Maquia"
on a fucking plane,
tiny screen like this
with shitty headphones.
- Crying in warm pee.
- Yeah.
And crying to three
pixels, and I was like...
And then the ending to
that just destroyed me.
I was like, "Why is it this one
that made me cry after all this time?"
- It's weird because
before, anytime I would cry,
just cry towards something,
that thing would be really,
really fucking special
to break down the brick wall that I am.
But nowadays-
- You stone of a man.
The obelisk known as Garnt's emotions.
- Exactly, but nowadays,
because I cry way more easily.
I dunno, it's weird,
sometimes I have empty cries
where I cry and I'm just like, it's over,
and then I feel nothing.
It's just like, I dunno, it's weird.
- I'm like, I cry and I feel amazing.
- [Garnt] Yeah, right.
- I just do it.
- It's like a release.
- Like I order a McDonald's the other day,
and I was like, "Why did
I do this?", I cried.
- I fucking cried to "Demon Slayer"
And I'm just like, "Why
did I fucking cry..."
- I get it, I get it, I get it.
The moment I feel sad, I'm
just like, (imitates crying).
(Joey imitates crying)
(Garnt imitates crying)
- I just get it over
with man. I just do it.
- Have you ever had those cries though,
where it doesn't feel
like you've released?
Where you just feel shittier?
- Are we talking about edging with tears?
- Not edging, you cry and then you-
- And then I climax with tears?
- No, there's those times where, you know,
you'd watch something really sad
and then you just let the emotions out.
And then after your tears have subsided,
you're just like, "Whew. All
right. I'm glad that's out."
You know, I feel good.
All of my emotions, all my
emotional baggage is out.
And then there are some times
where you would start crying,
and then once the tears have subsided,
you're just like, "Man, now I'm more sad
than I was before I started crying."
- That's like when I was 15 with breakups.
I'd cry and I'd feel worse.
- Oh, yeah yeah, yeah.
- Why did she leave me? (imitates crying)
(Garnt laughs)
And you know, getting back to funerals.
I wouldn't... like even if I wasn't,
'cause you know, sometimes
when you're like 10,
you didn't really
understand what's going on.
And then maybe when you get older,
you're like 15, 16 and it's like,
"Oh, it's this person
that you barely ever met,
but you have to 'cause
you're all connected."
I wouldn't know them so I wasn't sad,
but I would just get, I would just cry,
'cause I'm like, "Why is
everyone crying? This is so sad."
- Aw.
You cry because everyone
around you is crying.
- Yeah, 'cause if everyone
else is crying around me,
I'm like, "Fuck, well I gotta do it now."
Like a psychopath, like Mark Zuckerberg.
- This is human emotion, I must cry now.
- Sad.exe.
- There something about
being around people who,
when a room is filled with sad energy,
it just makes me get like that.
- It depends for me,
because say for example,
like the "Demon Slayer" movie,
everyone was crying like fucking
crazy at the end of that.
And I'm looking around like,
"Oh, it's now. I have to cry now."
I can't get the tears out right now.
- Like to me, I cannot
cry to a piece of media,
if there's someone else in the room.
Like, there's...
- I can't show the manly tears.
- Wait, wait. Sydney as well?
- Huh?
- Sydney as well?
- Especially Sydney.
- What?
- Really?
- Do you know why?
- 'Cause she'll be like,
"Oh baby man, you want a
little." (imitates crying)
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
Because, 10 minutes before the tears
even start forming in my eyes,
she's bawling her eyes out already.
She is, Sydney's...
- You're on cleanup duty.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- Sydney is so emotionally receptive,
that she will start crying five minutes
before the sad moments happen
and she'll be like in tears.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
If I'm watching with Sydney, I
am on emotional cleanup duty.
I'm like, "Oh, it's
okay baby. Don't worry."
I'm like, baby, I didn't
even get my point.
I didn't even like...
- Yeah, I guess you can't really be like,
"Oh baby, are you okay?" (imitates crying)
Hold on, gimme a second. (imitates crying)
- You've heard about relationships
where the guy comes too
fast and then it ruins it.
What about the one who cries too fast?
I can't get my tears in.
She's already decided it's
over before I've even started.
- 'Cause I remember,
"Your Name", I cried like a fucking baby,
the first time I watched "Your Name".
And it wasn't even because it was sad.
"Your Name" was to me,
the reason it's one of
my favorite anime films
is 'cause to me it's like
the perfect cinema experience
where there are so many
things happening on screen
that there's so many emotions
that I just get so absorbed
that my body doesn't know how to react,
other than just crying.
Sometimes I get emotional
and I don't know what to
do with it, and I cry.
- It's like an overwhelmed cry.
- Yeah, it's like an overwhelmed cry.
- Music normally does that for me?
I fucking cry at like
an E key. I don't know.
It's always the music for me.
- First note to "Black
Parade". (imitates crying)
- That is the music, the music
will make me cry instantly.
Like "My Hero Academia".
I don't know why I tear
up whenever I fucking hear
"You Say Run" with (indistinct) screaming.
I'm like, "Why, what's going on?"
- Yeah, I don't-
- Really?
- It's like I've been
programmed to a certain tune,
I'm like, (imitates crying)
- It's like Pavlov.
- Yeah yeah, yeah, I am
literally like a fucking dog.
- And so I remember second time
'cause the first time I went by myself.
- Sorry Mark Zuckerberg,
by the way, watching this.
(all laugh)
I know you normally like these segments.
I know you can't relate to this. Sorry.
- So the first time I went by myself
and the second time I was like,
"Sydney, you gotta see this film."
It's fucking, fucking amazing film,
gotta come see it with me."
And I remember, it was the moment
just before Radwimps start playing,
and that is the moment
where I start crying.
And I remember sitting in this film
and it was the second time,
I was getting as emotional,
I was getting as into it,
I was like getting absorbed
and I'm like, (imitates crying)
"It's coming, it's coming.
Radwimps about to play."
And then like a minute
before they start playing,
I'm just hear, (imitates
crying) next to me.
I'm like, "Oh God."
And it just took me out, I'm like...
of course, it's Sydney
balling her eyes out.
But yeah, that's why,
as much as I love Sydney
if I'm watching a sad thing,
if I want to have an emotional release,
I cannot watch it with her in the room.
- It's like, "Shut the fuck up".
- I'm like, "Sydney, can
you stop being emotional
for one second?"
- Did you watch his new movie?
- His, "Weathering with You"?
- Oh, "Weathering with You".
Yeah, "Weathering with You"
- "Weathering with you"?
Yes, I did watch it.
- Did you cry?
- I did not cry at that.
- Did you cry at, who's the
other director who's good?
- Mamoru Hosoda.
- Mamoru Hosoda
- Yeah, what's his? "Belle".
- I thought "Belle" was okay.
(Joey gasps)
It was...
- Would you say it was mid?
- Okay, here's...
- I watched it by the way.
- You watched it?
- I haven't seen it yet.
- What did you think of it?
Okay, did you watch it in cinemas?
- No.
- Okay, I feel like that's a movie
you have to experience in cinemas
because everyone I've talked
to who has seen "Belle",
they've talked about how
it's a fucking incredible
cinema experience with
the sound and the music.
There are definitely scenes in "Belle"
where I'm like, "I get that".
It feels like, especially
with the musical scenes,
the musical numbers, it
feels like these scenes
were made to be experienced in a theater,
with the surrounds sound and everything.
In terms of the plots and everything else,
it was not his greatest
movie, in my opinion.
- Was it one of those movies though,
that it was like cry bait?
- Yeah.
- So it was like the...
because that's the thing.
- I felt like it didn't earn it.
- But that's the thing is like,
sometimes it's so weird with fiction
that is obvious cry bait.
Where it's like, sometimes,
yes, I will buy into the
cry bait very happily.
Thank you very much.
And then there are other
times where it's like,
"Okay, you don't have to push
this in my face this much.
I'll cry when I wanna
cry or if I can cry."
- They have a digital world
in the show and a movie.
I just wasn't invested in this world.
I just didn't think it was like,
I couldn't see it being a
thing or why people would care,
'cause it was like, we're just
gonna make an online world
where you can be anything except you can't
and your avatars chosen for you, and also,
there seems to be like a class system
where some people are more important
than others in this world.
- Why does that just
sound like "Summer Wars"?
- And I was like this is-
- It is exactly "Summer Wars".
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- I was like, how do you know
it's a Hosoda Mamoru movie?
- He's made the same movie again,
with "Beauty and the Beast" this time.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, it was "Beauty and the Beast".
That's what I was also like, what's this?
I wasn't... It was okay.
- It was okay.
(all laugh)
I agree with you.
- You know what I watched in the cinema?
- What?
- The Batman.
- Oh, how was it?
- Very, very good.
- Really?
- Have you watched it yet?
- No, no yet.
- Was it three hours?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- And I loved it.
- How was Robert Pattinson in it?
- Delightful, just a treat.
- Yeah?
- What a great guy, what a great guy.
- What a bloke.
- I saw a meme the other day.
It was like 2010, women
fawning over Robert Pattinson.
It was like 2020, men fawning
over Robert Pattinson.
(Joey laughs)
It's so true, dude.
- Hell yeah.
- It's good, it's a good
movie, it's good movie.
- Is it a good movie or
is it a good Batman movie?
- I think it's not that
much of a Batman movie.
- Really?
- I'd give it an 8.5.
- Because I'm like one of the weird people
who really don't give that
much of a shit about Batman.
I don't know, to me, it's just...
- I really like this
portrayal by Robert Pattinson.
- Yeah.
- I thought-
- Is it kind of more like...
Is it kinda more like on the
Joker side of storytelling?
- No, no.
- Or is it more like a Batman being-
- Oh, oh, well I suppose,
if that's the scale that we're going with,
I guess it would lean more
towards the Joker side.
- Okay. Okay. Yeah.
- But I wouldn't compare
it to the Joker either.
It's more like they clearly
wanna tell Batman as a character
through this kind of
somewhat realistic lens
of like, if Batman was a real person,
he would be a fucking weirdo.
- More like a human drama side of things.
- Well it's kind of
detective movie, but also,
they don't shy away from
showing Batman as being,
having a lot of issues.
- Yeah.
- Like the man's got problems.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You know, and...
- More money, more problems.
- Yeah, dude.
I liked the villain. I
thought it was pretty good.
- The Riddler this time.
- The Riddler. Yeah.
- Oh, it's Riddler, oh shit.
- I thought they had a good,
a really interesting take
on the Riddler that I liked.
I just had fun.
I was there for three hours.
Maybe towards the end,
I felt like it could have
hurried up a little bit,
but overall I wasn't
bored, I really enjoyed it.
I had a great time.
- I'm interested to see
what Riddler is like
in a movie of that caliber,
because to me, the Riddler is Jim Carrey.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's literally the opposite.
- It is opposite. Okay, okay.
- I think you'd both like
it if you watched it.
- I'm sure I would, yeah.
- And it's a great cinema experience.
It was fucking...
- The thing that's always
wondered me about the Riddler
is how the fuck would that
work in the age of Google?
You know, the Riddler comes
up with a riddle or something
and Batman's like, "Hold on a second.
Okay, I got the answer
now. I got the answer."
- I think I saw that in
a Buzzfeed article once.
(all laugh)
- It's like the one YouTube short
that he watched the other day.
And he's just like, "I remember that one.
I know the answer to that one."
- Oh fuck, I would look it up,
I would show you on TikTok,
but it's the algorithm's so shit.
- The only issue with
the movie is that I wish
Robert Pattinson was just
out of the costume more.
He's just so good, why-
- Does he do the gravelly,
like "I'm Batman"?
- Oh yeah, he does, yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- He's pretty good at it.
- He's just really good at
doing voices in general,
actually.
- He's just a good actor.
- He's a good actor.
- Right?
- Definitely.
- I watched "Good Time" again after.
I was like, you gotta watch "Good Time".
It's so good.
Please watch "Good Time", it's so good.
- This episode is sponsored by Harry's.
- As you guys know from all the other
Harry's ad reads we've
done, I use Harry's.
It's the only razor I use
when I wanna shave my face.
It's the only razor I trust
that actually does a clean shave,
even after the first few
times you've used it,
unlike the other razors
that I've used in the past.
So much so, that when I went to the UK,
I brought a suitcase full
of Harry's back to Japan
'cause you can't get it here.
- And new customers can redeem
Harry's trial set for just $3
when you go to harrys.com/trashtaste.
- Harry's believes you
shouldn't have to choose
between a close, comfortable
shave and a fair price.
So they give you both.
- [Both] Both?
- [Garnt] In fact, Harry's blades
are designed to stay sharp longer.
In a recent study, guys who
shaved four times a week
said their eighth shave was
as smooth as their first.
- What are you waiting for?
Harry's is giving their
best offers to you guys,
the listeners and viewers of the show.
New Harry's customers
can redeem a starter set.
You get a five blade
razor, a weighted handle,
foaming shave gel with
alloy and a travel cover
to protect your blades
when you're on the go.
That's a $13 value for just $3.
There's truly never been a better time
to try Harry's, Garnt.
Go to harrys.com/trashtaste
to try Harry's today.
- $3.
- Back to the episode.
- It's $3.
- I can't think of,
has there ever been a Batman
that I thought was interesting?
'Cause before the, okay,
I feel like before "The
Dark Knight Rises",
Batman just had an awful
streak of just bad movies
and that just made his...
- With DC in general.
- Yeah.
- Come on, mate, you don't
like the George Clooney Batman?
- What, with the fucking Bat credit card
and the fucking Bat nipples
and all that fucking shit.
Even the best thing about that
was fucking Arnold
Schwarzenegger as Mr. Freeze.
- Ice to meet you.
- I just feel like for the longest time
Batman was just either a boring
or comical character to me
and the most interesting characters
were the villains of Batman.
- [Joey] Yeah yeah, yeah.
- The only time I thought Batman
was an interesting character
was actually during the animated series.
- Oh yeah, very, very good.
- That was peak Batman for me.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
- Have you seen the animated series?
- Yeah, I love the animated series.
- How does this compare to
the animated series, then?
'Cause that, to me, that is good Batman.
- It's a different
experience there entirely.
I feel like it's hard to compare them both
when they're both trying to
do wildly different things.
- Right.
- I think.
That's also so good 'cause Mark Hamill
is the Joker in that, he's amazing.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- Fucking so good.
I don't know.
I don't feel comfortable
comparing it, almost.
I feel like it's not fair.
- It's apples and oranges.
- Not a fair fight.
I think you should just watch
it. You won't regret it.
Just watch it.
- Conclusion, watch it.
- Genuinely, it's definitely...
- No, I want to, I definitely wanna.
- This is just Connor talking
about media in general.
Go on, Connor, sell me on it.
- Oh.
- Just watch it.
- No, there's a lot of stuff
I'll tell you not to watch,
if I don't think it's worth your time.
This however is worth your time.
- Did you play the "Batman
Arkham" games as well?
- I loved the "Batman
Arkham" saga games, dude.
- My God, a story based
game that you play.
- It was hardly story.
The combat was fun and
punching, exploring and stuff.
- That's true, yeah.
- I don't know what the story was.
I know Joker was-
(both laugh)
- God dammit, I thought we had one thing
in common for once when-
- He's got goopy gamer brain.
- [Garnt] Yeah, goopy gamer brain.
- I liked it, and there
was also the combat trials.
That shit was fun as fuck.
- You did the combat trials?
- Because I was like...
I was addicted to getting
all the achievements on Xbox.
- Wait, you did side stories?
- Well, no, so I was
obsessed with gamer score.
(Joey laughs)
- That's like the last thing I do.
I hate it when there is like a fucking,
when there's a point in the game
where you can like do
a trial for the combat
or one of the game mechanics.
I'm like, "Get this shit
outta my face. I don't wanna-
- No, me too, me too.
- Yeah, okay.
- Unless there's achievements.
- Well.
- Okay.
- So you're an achievement hunter.
- I was, I was an achievement hunter.
So here's what happened, right.
When I first got my Xbox
and I discovered these achievement things,
I thought, "Oh well that's pretty cool."
That's a pretty cool
thing to strive towards.
And then my friend was
an achievement hunter
and I was like, "I wanna be
better than him at this"."
And so I was like, "Well,
I'm gonna start doing it.
And then I got kind of addicted to it.
I would research games that were easy
to get all of the achievements on,
and then buy them and do them
just to get the achievement score.
I had like 60,000 gamer
score or something.
You could only get about a
thousand a game normally.
So I had, but you got DLC
for some stuff as well.
I bought, "Lost", the game,
like this TV show "Lost"
specifically because you could get
all the achievements in like two hours.
- Really?
- Yeah, I don't know why.
- You just speed ran it?
- I was absolutely addicted
to getting these achievements
and "Arkham Asylum" was
one of them I got 100% on.
And it was really hard
because you had to do one of the trials
and maintain a combo of
like a hundred or something.
I can't remember what it was.
I remember it took a lot of attempts.
- You also had to collect all the-
- All the trophies.
- All the fucking Riddler trophies.
- Did all of that, and there was also,
you had to do all the stealth
missions perfectly as well,
Or something like that,
I can't remember exactly.
I remember it was really hard
getting all the achievements,
but that was such a good game,
that I didn't mind doing it.
- When was the last
time you did that then?
- Achievement collectors?
- Yeah.
- Not since I was like, oh, 18, 19.
When I went to university
and I had less time,
kind of realized that,
that wasn't that fun?
- It's not fun, it's not fun.
- I had gotten one of the
hardest achievements on Xbox,
ever.
- Right.
- Which is like staying
alive on "Dead Rising" for-
- Oh, for seven days straight.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] You did that?
- No, not that one.
It was another "Dead Rising" one.
Not the seven day one.
- What makes it so hard?
- Wait, that's on the first game, right?
- That's "Dead Rising 1".
- I've done all of them
on "Dead Rising 2".
- Oh shit.
- Which is I think...
no, they have like kill 1 million zombies
or something stupid.
- Right, right.
- Sorry, another three days
on, my mom would've killed me.
- You had to be, that that one was,
you had to be alive in like hardcore,
"Dead Rising Analyst" for seven real days,
like in the real world.
- How do you get that?
- What was the other one?
- You'd have to go in shifts,
surely, with other people, yeah.
- What was the one I did on...
All of them on "Dead
Rising 2" are really hard.
I remember that took so long.
- That's just like a difficult game.
- Yeah, there's some
games that, you know what?
Oh, maybe this is why I hate JRPGs.
JRPGs always had the hardest achievements.
- Yep, they did.
- Hands down, the most.
And they had the most
cruelest ones where like,
get this item, that if you miss it,
you can't go back and get it. Fuck you.
So that's I think that is what, genuinely,
stopped me from ever buying
a JRPG, for a long time.
- 'Cause, people have to be psychopaths.
- You do, you have to psychopaths.
- 100%, to do JRPGs.
- You do.
- We're looking at you, Joe.
Well, to be fair, how many times
did you have to play
"Persona 5" before you 100%-
- Like six times.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But I also 100% at "Final
Fantasy VII Remake" as well.
- Oh my.
Well that one's not too bad, I guess.
- That one's not too bad.
- Because I feel like that's
a third of the original game.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- I wouldn't dare do it with the original.
- Oh no.
- No, no, no, fuck that.
- I feel like they've become
a lot more accommodating
in these modern times,
- Yeah.
- Compared to like OG JRPG games
where they assume that
that's the only game
you're playing for the entire year.
- Yeah, they just assume
that's the only game
you have on that console.
- Yeah, and it's just gonna last you
the entire fucking time.
- Exactly, exactly.
- I'm trying to find my Xbox profile
so I can see what I've done.
I think it's this one?
- Isn't the hardest Xbox achievement
the fucking "Mega Man 9" one?
- What's that one?
- It's the one where you
have to beat the entire game
without getting hit a single time.
- Oh, so that's just a no hit run,
but an actual achievement.
- Yeah, which if you've
played any "Mega Man" game
is practically fucking impossible.
- No, what's the game?
One of the Tom Clancy
games had an achievement
for being the number one
ranked player in the world.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No joke.
- I remember, I think
I saw a WatchMojo video
a long time ago, which was like,
"The top 10 hardest Xbox achievements".
- I was like, top 10 list of games
that I'm never gonna buy.
And one of them, I already
owned, it's like "Gears of War".
So it was like, got to get
like a hundred thousand online kills.
- Yeah.
- In the first game,
but no one was playing the first game
after the third one came out.
- How would that even be possible?
Like how much, how many hours-
- You have to go a hundred
thousand matches with your mates.
- Right. Right.
- No. No, it's kills.
So you have to be averaging
like fucking hundreds.
- It's ridiculous.
- Yeah.
- That is, and "Gears of War"
is not an easy game to get kills in.
- Yeah.
- So, it's very difficult.
I can find this, I can find it.
All right, I've got the
list of all of these.
Some of these games are
just fucking stupid.
So, I have 51,000 gamer
score in Xbox. Right?
- So that's like what? 50 games? 45 Games?
- I have every single "C.O.D." game ,
I have every single achievement.
Every single "Halo" game, I
have every single achievement.
- Of course.
- Except for the newer ones.
Like, "Halo Wars 2" and "Halo Infinite".
I have all of them.
I did all of the, I don't know,
Did you ever do "Halo"?
There was those challenges
where you had to do certain
things without dying,
like the skull ones.
I did all of those.
- I only played "Halo 1".
- I've only played "Halo 1" and "Halo 3"
I didn't play "Halo 2".
- I got every single
achievement in "Blue Dragon",
which I remember having-
- "Blue Dragon"?
- Yeah.
- The JRPG?
- Oh, shit.
- I remember you were
talking about "Blue Dragon".
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- I think...
What's this one, what's...
Most rare, what's the
rarest one? Head trauma.
- Every type of melee weapon in his army.
- That's so weird, there's like rarity-
- That features a lot in "Dead Rising",
'cause everything is a weapon.
- I've killed, yeah, okay.
Some of these are like really low.
Some funny games I've done.
"Dorito's Crash Course 2".
- What?
- I've got all
of the achievements on
"Dorito's Crash Course 2".
- Why would you buy that game?
- It was free.
- No, the other question is,
why is there two of them?
- Yeah, it was really popular.
(Joey laughs)
I've got all the
achievements on "Red Dead".
I think that wasn't too hard.
What else have I done?
What weird games are these?
- So like, would you basically do nothing?
Would you basically do nothing
until you were 100% at these games?
- Yeah.
- I've played-
- "South Park" games.
- I've played the "South Park
Tower Defense" game. "Lost".
I have "Terminator: Salvation",
which I think I got 'cause that was easy.
But then it turned out to
be really fucking hard.
What's weird? What other
games do I have here?
God, most of these are
"C.O.D." and "Assassins Creed".
- "Happy Wars"?
- I don't even know what that is.
I didn't even do that one.
That must have been too hard.
- Guaca.. Wait, hold on.
What was that one out there?
"Guacamelee Super Turbo Championship".
- Dude, that was a good game, dude.
That's a good-
- "Guacamelee"
(Joey laughs)
- And then other games,
I couldn't do them all.
They're quite a lot of games, actually.
A lot of the "Gears of Wars"
ones were just like fucked.
- Yeah.
- "Forza", "Destiny".
Fuck dude, I've played
some weird ass games.
What's wrong with me?
- Well, I think as a kid,
you just played any game
that you could get your hands on.
- Yeah yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- And now they're like-
- FIFA.
- "FIFA", of course, of course.
- You've got one achievement on "FIFA".
- I don't know, I have "FIFA 09".
I got all the achievements on "Halo:Wars",
which one of them included
getting to the highest rank,
which takes like an
absurd amount of hours.
- Geez.
- Stupid amount of hours.
- Yeah, I mean, like.
- I don't think I've ever
got addicted to a game
that much that I wanted to 100% it.
- [Connor] No way.
- 'Cause, I think, the closest I've come,
actually, surprisingly,
is "Tales of Arise",
which was last year.
- Oh.
- Oh, shit.
- It's the first time where I actually
did the fishing mini game.
'Cause you know how every
game has a fishing mini game.
I was like, "What the
fuck... who's the fucking
what fucking loser plays
the fishing mini game?
And I'm like, this is actually
pretty fucking damn fun.
Collecting all the fish.
But yeah, I mean, recently
I've been playing,
"Horizon Forbidden West".
I'm like the one fucking person,
'cause everyone's playing
"Elden Ring" right now.
And I'm like, I'll get to
"Elden Ring" eventually
after I finish "Horizon Forbidden West".
And yeah, I mean it's-
- Is there a fishing mini
game in that one as well?
- I don't think there is.
(all laugh)
I was like, I was like...
- You're like, God, I wish.
- Can you fish in "Elden Ring"?
I think so.
- I dunno.
We're not like dark
souls or like souls born.
- I'd like to think there's fishing,
in an ideal world.
- We need a Twitter account to be like,
"Yes, you can fish in "Elden Ring".
- I feel like it's just every JRPG, right,
that you can fish.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's like a staple.
- I dunno how, why did
that become a trope?
- Because Japanese people love fishing.
- Do they?
- They love fish.
(Garnt laughs)
- Okay, they love eating fish,
that doesn't necessarily-
- They don't like catching it, though.
- A nation of fisherman.
- By the same logic,
shouldn't us British to love fishing,
'cause we're a fucking
island nation as well. Right?
- We're shit, we don't eat
fish. We're fucking idiots.
- What do you mean,
you got fish and chips.
- That's it.
- [Garnt] We eat cods.
- We eat one fish and like
salmon, if you're rich.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, why is that? Why is that?
Not only why is there a fishing
mini game in every JRPG,
but why is that 99% of them
have no effect on the
main story whatsoever?
- I'd be pretty shit if
you're fighting Zephyr off
and you're about to
fight him and he's like,
"Sorry, you haven't collected
all of the 19 different species of fish.
You are not ready to face me."
It's like, "Well, yeah, well, fuck."
I guess that would be weird.
- I think I would want a JRPG
where you're actually rewarded
at the final boss.
It would be like, the boss is like,
"You've done the fishing mini game. Ah."
- How did you know that sea
bream scales are my weakness.
Stop.
- They start with like half health.
- Yeah. (Connor hums)
Oh, where's my health bar gone?
- Well, I know some people
who are deadly addicted
to every fishing mini game in JRPGs.
I mean, Alan is that guy.
Alan is that guy who
boots up "Final Fantasy",
and then he spends like the first 10 hours
on the mini fishing mini game.
And then after he gets bored of that,
then he actually goes to play the game.
- Alan's that guy who actually does
the Mahjong mini game in "Yakuza".
(all laugh)
Let's be real, every
"Yakuza" player is like,
"Don't mess with us, we don't
know how to play Mahjong,
'cause no one fucking does that mini game
in the "Yakuza" games.
- Well, isn't the mini games
the main game in "Yakuza".
- Yeah, exactly.
Except the Mahjong mini game
'cause no one fucking
knows how to play it.
- Well, that is until you've
come along and played-
- And then I'm like, "Lemme show you.
Lemme show you how to do it".
- Yeah, how's your Mahjong
coming along, Joey?
- Really good, my addiction is growing.
- Your speed running an old Asian man.
- Yeah, I am. I am.
I went to a Mahjong parlor
for the first time, the other day.
- [Garnt] Oh, how was that?
- It's really fucking fun.
I mean like, you know...
I think that the general
stereotype of a Mahjong parlor
is it's fucking dark, it's
like smoke is everywhere.
Like basically fucking "Akagi", right.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
But I walk in and I've never
seen that many lights on,
in one room.
I came in, I was like, "Ah, fuck".
It's so bright.
And like, no one's smoking in there.
A lot of really young people, as well.
There was maybe two tables
that had older gentlemen
and everyone else was around our age.
- Was it all men?
- No, surprisingly.
Half of them, I'd say like
half, maybe 40%, were ladies.
- Oh.
- There were a couple tables
where it was just full of ladies,
just like sitting around.
- Right.
- But yeah, I went in.
I went with one of my childhood friends
'cause he's been getting
into Mahjong as well.
And he was like, "Oh,
we're gonna go to this one
in Ebisu".
- Yeah.
And I was like, "Why
this one in particular"?
And he's like, "Oh, the fried
rice here is fucking lit."
And I was like, "So are
we're gonna and play Mahjong
or are we gonna go for the fried rice"?
- You had fried rice with the...
- Yeah, you can order food
there, and to be honest,
probably some of the
best fried rice I've had.
- Wow.
- In Japan.
- Nice, while playing Mahjong.
- I'd believe it.
It feels like the kind of place
where you get a weirdly good meal.
- Yeah.
- I wonder, where did
Mahjong get this image
of it being a game for
old guys or old people?
- 'Cause it's always old people playing it
on the street and betting, normally.
- Is it, I never see that?
Normally, my entire-
- That's an assumption.
- My entire image of Mahjong
comes from media basically.
'Cause before moving to Japan, I'd never,
I guess I'd never seen
anyone playing Mahjong.
- I know where you're getting this, right.
POV. You're watching a movie, right?
It's a spy movie.
Let's say a spy movie
or any kind of movie.
They're undercover in
Indonesia, let's say.
Do they play Mahjong in Indonesia?
- Yeah, Southeast Asia,
it's pretty popular.
So they're playing,
let's say they're in
Indonesia on a mission.
Oh no, their cover's been blown.
We gotta start running through buildings.
Charge in the one building.
Oh, it's a food store. Chicken everywhere.
Run in the next room.
Oh God, it's a bunch of
old people playing Mahjong.
You've seen this scene like 500 times.
- Yeah, every time.
- It's always just old
people in a smokey room
playing Mahjong.
- Every Jackie Chan movie.
- When they bust through
the thing, and they're like,
they keep running through.
It's always there, always.
- And then they always do
some kind of corny one liner,
right, as they're running out of the room.
- Well it's either that
or it's like an old-
- Indistinct Asian shouting.
- It's almost like an old Kung Fu movie.
And you get into the bad guys' lair.
- Yeah.
- What's he doing?
He's sitting down playing Mahjong.
With his fellow, with his guys
asserting dominance, right.
That's the image I have of Mahjong.
Like in that dark smokey room
and everything like that.
- Well, I feel like
it's the poker of Japan
or like poker of Asia really?
- Yeah, definitely.
- It's like the kind of game
where gambling's not legal,
but me and the boys can
have a little wager or two,
you know.
- As long as it's under
the table, you know?
(both laugh)
- 'Cause like, yeah,
have you guys ever played bridge before?
- No, I'm not 90.
- No, no, exactly.
- I've heard of that game.
What is that?
That's a game, which I dunno-
- Is it a card game?
- QI them. (imitates siren)
It would've gone off an hour ago.
- It is a card game.
I dunno what the images,
I dunno if it's famous outside of the UK
or anything like that.
- Oh yeah, it's famous in the US.
And again, for being the thing
that people play in retirement homes.
- Old people play it, right?
- Yeah.
- And I remember,
I think it was in high
school or something.
One of our teachers for like this...
you know you have a free period sometimes,
and it's the end of term.
You could do whatever you like.
So this teacher decided
to teach us bridge,
just teach us the rules.
I got addicted at a point where
I'd joined the bridge club.
Yes, I was that kid
who actually joined the bridge club.
'Cause it had this image of, like Mahjong,
being what old retired people
play in retirement homes.
But like, it is fun as fuck.
Right?
- Yeah.
- It's kind of similar to Mahjong
in a sense where you
get given a bunch of...
it is kinda like poker
where it is luck based,
but it's also skill based.
But what I found most
interesting to bridge
is that it's a team game. Right?
So the basic concept is before each game
you have a partner who sits opposite you.
And you basically have to make a bet
on how many points you'd be able to get
in the hand you're about to play.
So you're kind of
communicating with your partner
and communicating and trying
to assess what everyone has,
by the bets that they're placing.
And I thought that was like,
I think that's super genius.
It's basically like UNO, but
before the UNO game starts,
you have to try and guess
what everyone else has.
You're working in a team.
- Cool.
- To me, I wanted to talk about it,
'cause bridge has this image
of being a boring game
that old people play,
but I think it's interesting as fuck.
And I haven't played bridge
since I was in school.
When I was in bridge club, I
got super addicted for a while
because I think it's a
genuinely fun game's.
- Yeah, it's the same with Mahjong, right.
I was like, before I started playing it,
I was like, "No, I'm
not gonna get into this.
This is what my grandma was into."
- [Garnt] Yeah yeah, yeah.
- But then when you
actually start playing it
you realize just how like intricate it is,
and it's not just like
a fucking, you know.
- Well, I didn't think of
it as an old people thing.
I think of it as a
really complicated thing.
- But it's interesting though, how,
even something like Mahjong,
which is a very complicated, deep,
and very mind intensive game
is associated with old people.
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- If you look at like the
pro scene, for example,
most people are like dudes
and chicks in their 20's.
- Well yeah, of course.
It's like chess in the parks in New York.
It's like, yeah, all the
old dudes are playing it
but it's the young
people who are the best.
- It's a PR thing, right?
When are we gonna get a Twitch category?
- Everything's a branding
issue, isn't it, guys?
Nothing can't be fixed with
a bit of branding and PR.
- Remember, literally just two years ago
where chess had the same thing
and then suddenly chess had
a fucking second Renaissance
with the explosion it's had on Twitch.
And now it's seen as like
this cool thing that-
- Mahjong's next.
- I'm gonna call it, Mahjong is next.
- You know what I wanna learn?
- The Vtubers are already on that shit.
- Yeah. Yeah.
That's the secret.
We need to get the Vtubers
to all start playing it.
- The Japanese Vtubers have
been on that shit for so long.
- Yeah. Right.
- Yeah.
- I think, weirdly chess
is one of those sports
where when you look at it on paper,
it just shouldn't be a spectator sport.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- Everything about it makes it
almost a bad spectator sport.
There's long gaps in between moves.
It's not that engaging.
Storylines are a little
harder to get across,
and it's visually not that exciting.
You look at a board for
like 15 minutes at a time.
If you're lucky, they'll
make a move every 15 minutes,
in the World Championship.
But somehow I think just out of pure,
like being a very solid
and ubiquitous game,
it's managed to somehow carve a good niche
and a pretty strong one.
But also chess has also had great success
by having the branding of
being the smart mans skill.
The smartest of smarts play chess.
- Well, I think the problem with chess
as a spectator sport is
that, with a lot of sports,
you look at the higher level players,
you look at, you know,
traditional sports like football,
basketball, maybe even
like league or whatever.
And you can, even as a normal person,
you can appreciate the skill being showed.
You see someone doing a speed
run of Mario 64 or something.
You're like, damn those are some-
- No words needed.
- Yeah, no words needed. That's
fucking speaks for itself.
But me watching a high level chess game,
the chessboard championships is like,
I've never understood the feeling
of that side character in "Dragon Ball Z",
where the characters-
- That explains the moves.
- Yeah, yeah, no, like
where the main characters
are following the fight perfectly.
and you just see, like
you just see nothing.
This is me watching high level chess.
- That's why I think chess
has gotten really good
in recent years at having the,
kind of what a lot of e-sports are doing
and what traditional sports
are doing for a long time
where one of them is the one
that's saying what's going on,
and one of them's helping add color
and break it down and really explain it.
Chess has been really
good at that recently.
'Cause I mean, I like watching
the World Championships,
but even then there are periods
where nothing happens for 20 minutes
and it's like, I got shit
to do, man, like, come on.
- Yeah, sometimes I get recommended a clip
of Magnus Carlsen streaming
or something like that.
And it's just like an out of context clip
of this fucking 500 IQ move.
And then the move happens
and I don't even know it's happened.
Because it was like five moves
ago that he reacted to it.
And I remember,
I think one of the funniest
videos I've seen is just like,
I can't remember the exact video,
but it's a parody video
of someone commentating
on a Magnus Carlsen stream.
And it's just a normal person
commenting on his stream.
And it's just like,
"And Magnus Carlsen
leaves his knight hanging.
Is he gonna take it?
Is the opponent gonna take it?
No, he doesn't take it.
He doesn't take the free knight.
Oh, now he's left his queen hanging.
Is he gonna take the queen?
Magnus, the queen is right there.
No, he doesn't take the queen.
And he looks like he's in
an awful position right now.
And he resigns, Magnus Carlsen resigns.
I don't know what's going on.
And it's just...
It's exactly how I feel watching,
a high level chess game
when I'm just like,
there is the hanging queen right there.
Why is Magnus Carlsen not
taking the hanging? Oh.
And he's just resigned for no reason.
And he scrolls to the comments section
and it's never the top comment
that's explaining what's happening.
It's always buried a few comments down.
Just be like, can someone
just explain to me
what I just witnessed, please.
But yeah, I mean like that's why,
one game I really want to get into,
'cause it sounds super interest,
it always looks super interesting to me,
but I'm fucking terrified of
possibly getting into, is go.
Go seems to me like, that is just like...
chess is complicated by itself.
Go, to me, even just the concept of go,
it seems like what
viewing a bottomless pit
that you cannot see the end of.
- My granddad was into go
and he was really good at it.
And he tried to teach me
when I was in high school
and I was like, "I don't know
what the fuck is happening".
I know you're showing me the
ropes really nicely and kindly.
But all I'm thinking is,
"Ooh, black and white stones".
- All I know is that Google's documentary
about the AI they built
to beat the best player.
- And then I read, "Hikaru No Go"
and I was like, "I
understand what's happening."
- No, I like, because I also
read "Hikaru No Go" as well.
I read all of it.
And I remember there was a point
where they tried to explain
what was going on to the viewer.
And I think halfway through
the manga, they just stopped.
They just stopped showing the matches,
and they just like,
"I'm not even gonna try and
explain it. This guy wins."
And you see...it's a manga that just,
it bases its hype on of people,
off of like character reactions,
as opposed to what's
going on in the match.
- It's not very good, is it?
- I think it's because they
just assume you are like...
- They figure, you got it.
- You're 15 volumes in,
you should know how this works by now.
We're not gonna explain it to you.
- I still don't think I
understand how football works
and I watched all of..
- What you mean football?
- Sorry, American football.
- Oh.
- Oh, okay.
- Sorry, football.
I don't know how it football works.
And I watched, I read
all of "Eyeshield 21".
I think I understand how it works.
- I don't think that's very realistic.
You're not gonna be like,
you're not gonna be watching
the Super Bowl and be like,
"Well, he could have done
a devil bat ghost there.
Why didn't he?"
- But you know, when
you're watching something,
you're like, "I feel
like I should understand
how this base game works yet I don't".
Baseball's another one that
I've watched stuff about
and I'm like, "I think I
understand the baseball,
but I'm not so sure."
- Really? Baseball's
fairly easy to figure out.
- I don't understand
when they swap that much,
but then again, I've never watched-
- After three strikes, right?
- Three strikes, right?
- And they swap teams.
- Yeah.
- So you get three goes
and then everyone...
No, 'cause then they all,
everyone on the field swaps?
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- [Crew Member] Better strike out.
- Yeah yeah, yeah, so, it's
not three throws, right?
- No, it's three...
- Three strikes.
So when you throw in baseball,
it can either be a strike or a ball.
- Right.
- And you have a strike zone.
- Yeah.
- That pitchers have to throw into.
- Yeah, yeah. I know that, I know that.
- So when it's three strikes-
- That's one batter out.
- And then they're out,
and when it's three outs, they switch.
- Right. Right.
- And there are usually nine innings.
- I never really like, even
when I read stuff about it,
I'm like, baseball just doesn't look fun.
Am I bad? Am I wrong?
- No, baseball's hella fun, dude.
- Really?
- Yeah.
I love watching baseball.
- There's a lot of sports
that are fun to play,
but not fun to watch.
- I feel like it would be fun to play,
- To me, that's baseball, that's golf.
That's cricket. Sorry Indians.
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm offended.
(all laugh)
- Like I have fun playing them,
but watching them, I kind of fall asleep.
I mean, I think kind of same
with American football as well,
'cause I think my problem
with a lot of American sports
growing up with somebody watch,
you know, real football
and a lot of Europeans...
- Whoa.
Yes, I fucking said it.
It's the amount of starting and stopping
and the advertisements that go in between.
- Yeah.
- That's, yeah.
- That's what I don't
really like about the NFL,
the American football is like, yeah
it's just way too many starts and stops.
- I'm just like, right
when a play is happening
and you're like, "Oh shit,
here we go. Oh, they stopped."
- I don't understand,
this is again for someone who's...
Again, I think I understand
how American football works.
I don't, I'm not sure entirely.
- What do you mean, you think
you understand how it works?
- I think I understand the rules.
Right.
- Okay.
- But even when I'm watching it,
my older brother really
likes American football,
but I'm just thinking like,
why would I ever wanna
watch this over rugby?
- Yeah, I'd much rather watch rugby.
- There's no point where I've ever watched
a American football game and thought,
"Fuck, I wish this was rugby."
- I think...
- Sorry, there's no point
that I haven't thought that.
Every single time I
watch American football,
I'm like, "I just wish this was rugby".
- I think just because...
I'm gonna be the American here.
I'm gonna be the American stick...
- Tell me why, 'cause I don't know.
- Sticking up for American football.
Because, I think,
even though I just complained
about the stop start,
I think the beauty of American football
is that it comes in bursts, right.
And when that burst happens,
I don't think there's another sport
that could really compete
with American football
with just the amount of-
- Hype.
- The amount of small things happening
in such a short period of time.
'Cause there are so many things
going on when it's in play.
- Australian football would
like to have a word with you.
- Okay, I haven't watched
Australian football, Joey, okay.
- That's our footy.
- Okay, Joey. Okay, Joey.
But, to me, that is the real
strength of American football.
- It's super intricate,
especially when you know,
when you have an idea of
like, "Oh, that's this plan,
they're doing all these different things.
That's fun to watch, but
it's like, it happens-
- So quickly.
- It happens so quickly.
And then by the time you're like,
"Oh, that was kind of
cool", then they're stopped.
- Also that's why I love basketball.
Basketball is so fun to watch.
- Basketball's really fun.
- Basketball's hella fun.
- Yeah, it's sports that have
a constant movement going.
That's why rugby is so
fun because it's like,
except if it's a penalty or whatever,
it's just like constantly
moving, you know?
- Yeah, like to me...this is a preference.
As a spectator sport, I do
like when the rules are...
how can I word this? Like, fluid?
You know, there's like
the offense and defense
can change at any time.
If there's a sport where, you know,
you have an offensive
team and a defensive team,
and then they swap at certain intervals,
like American football, like
- Baseball
- Baseball.
cricket or whatever.
Then that's like... I like
it when anything can happen.
When there's more randomness of someone-
- You want "Mario Party"?
- Yeah, basically.
(all laugh)
- What are the items?
Banana, put some banana
peels on the baseball field,
and then I'll watch.
- Yeah, I mean every sport has-
- You should play the
"Mario Baseball" game.
You'd love that game.
- Didn't they bring out
a new "Mario Soccer"?
- Yeah, they are.
- Is there a "Mario Baseball" game?
- Yeah, on Game Q.
- "Super Mario Strikers"
- No, "Strikers" is the soccer.
- That's the football-
- "Sluggers" is the baseball.
- Oh, "Sluggers".
- Oh my God, dude, that's
a blast from the past, bro.
I tried to get that game for
Christmas for so god damn long.
My parents had to buy it off
some shady Chinese website
and it turned up and my parents,
and I also was too young.
I didn't know about region lock.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And my mom, bless her,
she tried so god damn hard
to get a copy of this game,
but they never sold it in Europe.
- I found "Sluggers"
the other day, actually,
in Akihabara and I bought it
and I played it for the
first time since I was 12
and I was like, "This game's godlike".
Easily the best "Mario" sports game.
- No, "Strikers" was really good.
- "Strikers" is good, but-
- "Strikers" was so good.
- I'm just, I'm more of a a fan of-
- I hope they bring out a new one.
- But I'm more of a fan of
baseball than foot, than soccer.
- No, no football, you were right.
You were right the first time, Joe.
- No, it's soccer.
- You were right the first time.
- It's soccer. It's soccer.
- You were right the first time, Joey.
- It's soccer.
I refuse to call soccer
football. Oh my God.
- But anyway, that's been
this episode of "Trash Taste".
So we did talk about a
wide bunch of things today.
- Very random episode.
- Yeah, very random episode,
from wildlife to sad boys to
back to video games. Right?
- God, I wanna eat a fucking
tortoise so bad, dude.
God, I wish I could have
tried that tortoise, man.
I bet it's so good.
- What is it with you and extinct food.
- Oh.
- First it's the extinct banana.
- I was born in the British Empire.
I would've been the one
guy there, like fuck,
don't let him on the fucking boat, dude.
He's just gonna start bringing on
weird fucking animals to eat.
(all laugh)
- The reason why it
hasn't had a genome name
is because Connor cooked it.
- Dude, I would've been like,
"Sorry, scientists. Man, you gotta try it.
Oh wait, you can't, I ate it all".
- Okay, here's the thing.
Since we're past the era
of discovery where you-
- Are we adding in another
topic before we end this?
- I guess so, I guess so.
Now that you mention it.
- Go on, then.
- Since we're past the era of discovery,
I'm jealous of, not the
people who were the first
to discover this new land,
but imagine discovering a new animal
and being the first
person to ever taste it?
(all laugh)
- Well, the people who tasted
it of your type of people.
- What do you mean?
- Well, I feel like,
you know, in Australia,
I'm sure Aboriginal
people had eaten a bunch
of the stuff that was there.
- Yeah, of course.
- Sure, sure, sure.
- But yeah, I guess you
would be the first foreigner
to try it.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
- To document it.
- I guess.
I think to me, that's way more exciting
than discovering new land mass.
- Think about all the foods
that might have tasted good,
but the first guy who had
it thought it tasted bad.
So he never, we never tasted it.
- Yeah. but it's also like,
there's a terrifying element to it, right?
Because you don't like...
could you imagine the first
person who drank cows milk?
That would've been fucking terrifying.
- Would it have been terrifying
or just really weird?
- Yeah, it's like, "Ooh,
this weird white shit
just came out from the tit of a cow."
I'ma drink it, you know?
- I respect it, I respect it.
- Got big balls, big balls.
- No, they probably saw
the little cow drinking it,
and thought, "I'll have that".
- It's like, "Oh, if he's..."
- Can't blame that.
- Yeah.
- Anyway, that's been-
- That's been "Trash Taste.
- That's been "Trash Taste".
- You know who else
likes milk? Our patreons.
- They love milk.
And probably giant tortoise too.
- I was thinking the entire time,
how the fuck am I gonna
segue way into the patreons?
Milk.
- Milk.
- You like milk, right?
- This guy loves giant
tortoise, right here.
- I thought you said something
completely different,
I thought you said, do you
know who we love to milk?
(all laugh)
Our patreons.
- Wow, Garnt.
- Hope you enjoyed this
episode of "Trash Taste".
See you guys.
- Hey, if you wanna be milked,
then make sure to go over to our page
on patreon.com/trashedit.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us memes in the subreddit
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah.
- Anyway, that's been "Trash Taste".
We'll see you guys next week.
- [All] Bye.